welcome to simply learns python tutorial
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead today we're
going to cover python
one of today's highly utilized
programming languages for its many
diverse
uses i'll be working in pycharm pycharm
is put out by jetbrains that's
www.jetbrains.com
pycharm slash where you can download it
the benefits of using
pycharm is it creates a virtual
environment so you can change what
version of python you're using
you can make all kinds of alterations in
there for this tutorial
any python ide will work but we'll be in
the pycharm
setup it is a really good setup to use
on there and again you can download it
here from the
jetbrains website so in the pycharm
environment and if you're not using this
you'll need to follow whatever
ide setup you have for doing a new
project we've created a new project and
we're going to create a new scratch file
this scratch
file we can call whatever it is we want
it's going to be a python file since
we're working in python we'll call it
scratch
3 python we can also rename this you can
see i have a number of other scratch
files delete them remove them whatever
you need to do
so we're going to be working on our
python in this ide
and again whatever ide you use will work
just fine for this python tutorial
and we're going to start with variables
in python the most fundamental building
block you need
variables are entities of program that
hold a value
x equals 100. the boxes holding a
variable would be
the name given to the box and if you
studied basic algebra
x equals 3 x equals 100 it goes a little
bit beyond just equaling numbers because
we can also do words but we're going to
look at just
variables and let's go ahead and pull
that up in our user interface
and see what that programming looks like
in the script language so
in python we can do something like print
this is a simple print statement so
whatever we put in here is printed back
out
so we're going to put in here meet jane
and let's also have it print
jane works as a software
engineer and then let's also do one more
print line just you can see we're
looking at print
and then we have elise is jane's
manager and in here you can run it a
number of ways we'll go underneath
run and here's our alt shift f10 also
does this and it asks me what do i want
to run i want to run the scratch 3
because i have multiple scratch files in
there and we'll click on there and it'll
run it if you're on like a different id
you might pop up with the black box it
prints it out and you can see here it
says meet jane
jane works as a software engineer elise
is jane's manager they always take that
space
out so it just looks nicer so we have
that and it's kind of nice if you just
want to print something out and there
certainly is
a lot of times when you want to print
the title of something
you might have your html code on the
server and you print it out and that's
what people actually see if they go to
the python
and it accesses that python code it'll
print out the html and they'll just be
text
printing it out now this is all great
let's go and put a comment in here just
so we can track what's going on
a comment uses the hashtag uh so this
just tells it this isn't code this is
just a comment for our notes while we're
programming and this over a little bit
so you have better
space on here instead of typing jane
every time
we can also store it as a variable so
let's go ahead and store that
and we'll call it name equals jane so
now we have the variable name
and now we can do something like this we
can go print there's our brackets
we want meet and i'm just going to do a
simple comma
everything that's separated between
commas will print out in a row so we
have meat
and then we'll just do the name and if i
run this you'll see
meet jane jane works as a software
engineer elise is jane's manager and
then just says meet jane
because we replaced the name with jane
and we'll take this off the top
i'm just going to delete that out of
there so we can move on to this next
setup with the
variables and we can also go print this
is kind of a cool system because i can
now do
string we can hold a space for a string
works as
a software engineer and then if you're
going to put a placeholder
in here it has to know what the
placeholder stands for and this is one
of the
formatting options when you print
something out so do something simple
like this we have a placeholder for a
string
works as a software engineer except the
placeholder is supposed to be inside the
brackets
and when we hit run you'll see meet jane
and then he also prints
jane works as a software engineer and
see that right down here in the
output the terminal output from the run
so instead of having to type
jane over and over again we can now put
a placeholder in there
and the same thing with the last set up
print elise is and there's our
placeholder
the percentage sign and the s and then
we have name afterward
let's go ahead and run that and you can
see here that we've now printed out the
the first one
meet jane and notice this puts more a
little bit more it has one space in here
but you don't really control the spacing
on here so when we do a formatting
and we insert it as part of the format
you can see right here we put the name
it now has a nice format like i couldn't
do this with a comma but i can certainly
do this down here with the apostrophe s
for elise's jane's manager and then we
can also instead of having jane up here
maybe jane got fired
and may got hired well let's just say
there's a second employee named may so
now we have the name may in here and i
can run this
and you'll see it now prints meet may
may works as a software engineer elise's
maze manager so we've just
swapped may in for jane and then one
other
important feature of python variables
is we could have name two also equal to
may keep the same name on there and
let's go ahead and print
we'll do id of name
and then i also want to print the id of
name 2.
and what the id does is the id goes in
there and says hey where is this name
coming from
let's go ahead and run that and you'll
see it actually gives us a memory
address
and so one of the things that you find
out about
python is to help save memory let me
just swap this out here
in python variables with the same value
hold the same
memory space so we have name equals to
may name two equals may
we print the idea of name and name two
and you'll see that they occupy the same
memory space
now if we happen to swap one of these
out we'll do jane again
and we run it they now have two
different memory spaces so even though i
make changes in here
this is one of the ways that python is
really good about saving memory
in the computer and the last thing we
want to note here which leads us into
the
next piece of programming is that this
is a string up here
name equals jane so we're talking about
different data
we really have to also talk about
different data types
and very specifically we're going to
look at numerical data so we talk about
numeric data talking numbers the various
types of numeric data
are integer float and complex
there are an advanced programming
additional numerical data types which
have to do how it stores the data but
these three are the ones that you need
to know about
to get started in your scripting
language and the most commonly used
and so an integer is just simply that
it's a number equals five and then if i
print
and you can always find out what type of
variable you have
if you do a type on it so we're going to
print type number and so if i run this
it comes out and it says class integer
down here so this is an integer number
and you can also do
negative on these so if i run minus 5
it's still a class integer whether it's
plus or minus
and the most the second most commonly
used number is your float
and it's just like it sounds we have
let's do a number
equals 5.6 and if you notice i used the
same
variable name num on there so i can
actually take this and i can just copy
this
and at some point we'll talk about ways
of not having to recopy your code so you
can create definitions but let's go and
take a look at this we have our float
our number now equals 5.6 and if we
print the number type
we'll see that it is first an integer
and then a float value and let's do this
just to
number just remember we're looking at
number and then
finally complex so if we have a
complex number we'll go ahead i'm going
to keep number in there
usually you don't leave it as number
because then it confuses the code
later on but just for this particular
piece of code we're going to keep it
number
and i'm going to do 5 plus 6j
and let's go ahead and print that out so
we can see what these look like
and here's our number comma type number
and let's run this
and let's see we got here we have a 5
which is an integer
5.6 which is a float so it has a decimal
place there that's what the float stands
for so your 5.6 5.7 5.8
and then we have 5 plus 6j is a
complex number and if you remember from
math
complex number is based off of i squared
equals minus 1 or the square root of
minus 1 is that imaginary number now
i'll be honest with you i don't use
imaginary numbers much unless
something comes up where i take a square
root of a minus one and then i end up
with a return of a complex number
so it's important to know it's there and
know what it is when it comes up
and with anything you do have to be pay
attention when you do
conversions so we can convert these
things back and forth and let's go ahead
and put a little note here
versions and let's start by oh let's
just do here's our print
and we'll go ahead and do our number
comma
type back to what we were doing before
so we know what the type it is
and type number so that's just from
before on there and let's say we want to
convert it
from a regular number to a float and we
can simply do
something that looks like this and let's
go ahead and pull ways there's our
number
but i want to convert it so i'm going to
convert it to float and then if we do
that over here too and i go float
that in brackets so we're going to print
this out and if i run this
we now have 5 as a class integer 5.0
is a float so i've converted it to a
float here and we can also
convert this to a complex just like we
did here with float
i can simply put in complex and we'll do
that over here also
complex number and if i run this we now
have
5 plus oj so this is a complex number
there's no actual negative
imaginary numbers is part of it so
you're going to get just a zero in the j
part um so this is one way to convert it
and you convert it this way we can also
convert it back
so you can convert to any between any of
these and let's take our number
and let's make it worth 5.6 so if you
remember correctly this is now
a float and if we wanted to take that
float value
print integer of our number and of
course type
integer of our number and if we run this
we started off here with 5.6
so by default it automatically makes it
a float value and here we have it we
converted a float to a float so it's not
going to really do anything
and then we convert it to an integer and
look what happens as an integer as an
integer it just truncates
the six right off so you gotta be very
careful when you're going the wrong
direction on this so if you're going
from
float to integer you're gonna lose a
decimal value if you're going from
integer to flow which is very common
thing to do
especially with data science you don't
lose anything you just gain the decimal
place
so if i when we did it earlier we had
five became 5.0 and then you can see
where it becomes a complex number
and we can do that just about any
direction you want with the conversion
python is really nice that it lets you
do that but you do have to be careful
that you don't lose
information that you need so we've
looked at variables
we've looked at numerical variables and
how they differ the next question is
what happens if you have a lot of data
you really can't just number one number
two number three
that's really not going to work in
programming so three of our basic
lists is lists in python a list is a
collection of data and it can hold
values of multiple data types
so you can see here we've set a value of
variable x
and we'll set it equal to 189 a a0b
and it can store that in there there's
also the tuple so we have list
tuple and set the tuple almost has the
same format
as the list but instead we put the
curved brackets around it
and what this means is a tuple is an
immutable collection of heterogeneous
data
big mouthful there what it means is once
i set the tuple i can't go in there and
change
one piece of it as far as the tuple is
concerned that's one variable where a
list
is a list of sub variables 189a 0b
a tuple you can't change anything in
here now you can access it the same way
you do a list but you can't make any
changes on this tuple other than
completely overwriting it and then
finally there's a set
and we put brackets around it now
there's some other more
complex data sets that go with this that
go above
our data type collections of data but
these are the three basics and a set is
an unordered collection of unique
heterogeneous data so it's unique
so if you put in one five three hey six
python and i try to add six in here
you'll only store one value of six
since these are all unique in here so
let's jump into our
ide and let's create a list remember it
uses square brackets that's how we
denote that this is going to be a list
let's just throw some numbers in there
four five
seven five so now i have a list and we
can do a simple thing like
print the list and if we run this we'll
see it come out down here
as one four five two seven five
and one of the cool things about lists
is that these are indexes
and this is kind of important to
understand what the index means
so we'll go ahead and print list and it
always starts with
zero so if i run this and i print zero
it's going to print the one because
that's in the zero place
and if we print here's our list we print
a one on there
and we run that we have four that's in
the one place so
zero one two three four five so there's
zero through five and this is
interesting because if we print
let me go back up here to the top i'm
just gonna print lin
which stands for length of list this is
going to return the length of the list
and i'm going to run this
and you'll see it says there's six
things in there but it starts at zero
so we reference them as zero through
five now if you're new to this
that can be confusing especially when
you're jumping back and forth
in your code so always remember this is
point zero
through five it's not one through six is
zero through five but there are six
entities in the list that's the length
of the list and we showed you here we
can access
your zero index your one index you can
also access it from the right hand side
by simply adding a negative number in
there so if i add a negative one
and i run this helps if i actually put
the list in front of it there we go run
you'll see that it points to the last
one in the list so negative one is the
five
this again a little confusing you can't
do a negative zero
so negative one going backwards it
starts at one and if i change the
negative one
say to two you'll see it'll go to the
seven prints the seven out there
so we can do some very basic indexing
and look at any one of these entities
in the list and then get the length of
the list so we know how long
our list is now really common is not
just to want one entity
instead of wanting just one entity in
here let me just get rid of
some of the notes here so that we can
see what this looks like i might want to
access
the first four values so i can do print
list 0 4. and your first thought
might be that we count this 0 1 2
3 4 which would be five entities but we
don't count the four
so this is zero to three so whenever you
see this axis from left to right
positive side it's going to give us the
first four element but it starts with
zero
zero one two three which is our one four
five two and
since we're starting from the beginning
you can always just leave the zero out
and we can do something like this this
gives us the same answer whether you put
the zero in or leave the zero out
it automatically assumes you're starting
from the beginning of the list
likewise we can start from position two
and go forward and if you notice here we
get five two seven
five position two if you look at this we
have zero
one two two points to the five position
so if you're going from left to right
you just say hey i want position two and
you get everything to the end and we
could also put a second number in here
like four
that's just two three you get two values
remember it doesn't include the four on
here
it does include the two just like you
can do
indexes with negative numbers i can now
do minus
four so this means that i'm starting
with zero i can leave it out
so the python way is to leave it out you
don't need all that extra script and it
goes
up to a negative four well where is
negative four here's one
two three four so this should go up to
this location but not included and sure
enough we get one
four so it goes up two negative four
remember when you're reading it this way
from left to right you don't include the
minus four
include the first one but not the second
one and you can also put the negative
over on the other side and go minus
four and if we run this one now we get
five
two seven five so we have one two three
four and remember it's on the left hand
side so we include it so we have five
two seven five coming out on the bottom
and the last really fun trick you can do
let me just take the minus four
out is i'm gonna add a second colon here
and a two and i'm gonna run this and it
should print out
every other one so goes one it skips one
so it counts at one
two one two and we get the one five and
seven coming out and you can see that
down here
and you can add in any of your other
numbers in here so we can start at one
instead of at zero and now you get four
two five so again we're skipping every
other one but now we're starting with
the digit in the index number one place
last thing to note is that these are all
integers if i put
a 1.0 in and i run it it's going to give
me an
error it says i can't slice a float
value even though it knows what one is
it needs to be an integer and that's
important to know if you're slicing your
data into thirds
i don't know how many times i forget to
do that change it convert it back
to an integer and it'll say i can't
slice 3.6666 or whatever it is let's
remember to convert that into integers
so another thing to remember about lists
they can be mixed
so i can come in here and instead of it
being all in this case we had all
integers
i could easily put python in here and
instead of seven we'll do seven point
four comma five and if i print this out
let me just take that out of here
and by the way this this functionality
of the index works identical no matter
what's in your list but we come in here
and you'll see i have one for
python 2 7.45 and lists are mutable
so just like i did just like i
referenced um
the index i can say list of let's do one
which is going to be the fourth place
equals
let's do hello and if i print my list
now you'll see down below where it comes
out
goes from 1 4 python to 7.45 to
1 hello python to 7.45
and because these are mutable with the
lists we can also do something like list
dot
append and we can append simply learn
and now if i print my list out and i run
this
you'll see that i've added simply learn
to the end of the list and if i do a
link to the list it's now gone from
six to seven oh let's just do that real
quick print
length of list so now it's seven so
we've added one more unit to the list
they're very mutable very flexible use
of
setting up lists and then we can also
take this list
let's do a new one we'll call it nested
we can create nested lists
uh what that means is that here's my
brackets to define that it's a list
and i can fill this with whatever
objects i can think of these can be
anything but we'll stick to numbers i'll
do one two and then i'm gonna also
create a nested list and we'll create
two comma three comma four
so now i have a list within a list so
now we have a nested list and if we
print this let's just print
our nested list out you'll see down
below it prints it out just like i typed
it one
two comma two three fours and nested
inside the nested list
and then another option to append is we
can also do
nested extent and we could go in here
and let's let's create my nested loop
so i'm adding a nested loop to a nested
loop this is kind of interesting because
you'll see here i have
a sub list attached to the list and i'm
going to take the nested extent i'm
going to extend this on here and if i
run this
if i take this and run this let me make
sure i print the nested again
you can see how it's been transformed
and i got one two
two three four and it's added the seven
eight nine on there now
i was just adding one nested list on
here i'd probably just append
brackets around seven eight nine but if
you were adding multiple
nested lists on here you might do
something then you want to use the
extend on here so we have
one two uh sublist 234 sublist 789
and sub list 567. i've added two
different new
nested lists onto this so we've looked
at lists
we've covered indexing of lists we've
covered appending or extending in
sub-lists
let's go ahead and talk about tuples and
tuples are really important
i am amazed when i first heard about
them i was like why why have a list and
why have a tuple
so the tuple is your curved brackets
around in this case we're going to do
one two
three and the most important thing to
know about the tuple is i can't change
it
i can't go in there and change the one
to a zero now i can change tuple and
have it equal something else
but i can't change the pieces of the
tuple and that's what's so important
about the tuple on this and you'll see
when i print it
it also prints it with the curved
brackets so that lets me know that this
is
immutable i cannot change the tuple now
we can access the tuple just like you
did the list i can print
tuple position one and if i run that
it's going to print two because remember
we start with zero
one i can do just the same way we did
the indexing i can do
up to one which should print just the
one because zero and it doesn't include
the one
there's our tuple comes out with one
comma so a little different output
you'll see this kind of notation when
you're accessing slices of a tuple and
you know all the different functionality
for indexing is the same we can even do
it in reverse
we didn't show you that on the list but
this works just as well on the list
instead of the two for skipping we can
do a minus one and that just goes in
reverse
so now i have a tuple of three two one
uh so i talk about it not being able to
be changed
if we take and just get rid of the print
for a second and let's print
let's do this tuple of 1
is now going to equal 7. if i run this
it's going to throw an error because we
cannot change the pieces of the tuple i
can reassign something else to
tpl my variable but i can't change it
it's
immutable and one of the very common
uses
of a tuple is to use it as a key for
something else
now we're not going to cover keys and
codes in this tutorial but imagine if
you
have an address to a house and the house
is 123 main street and someone can just
change that address
then your house just kind of jumps all
over the place so you want that address
to be
unchangeable immutable and this is like
a key code so it's probably a key
to some data so it's a reference usually
at some point or
some kind of data that can doesn't needs
to be set and unchanged
when you set it for a tuple and we can
do there's some other cool things we can
do with a
tuple now let's just take this one we
can do something
you can there's what they call packing
and unpacking tuples
so just like we assign the tuple one two
three i can also do
tuple equals we'll do five six
eight just because and if i print tuple
and we run that
it's still going to create a tuple out
of it and so we're saying hey this tuple
is equal to
these three values whatever they are and
now this variable is equal to these
three values and automatically converts
it into a tuple
if you do it that way and we can unpack
our tuple i can do
a comma b comma c equals tuple and if we
print
a comma b comma c run that you'll see we
get our 5
6 8 right back so we can unpack it and
pack it you see this a lot when you're
doing definitions
in programming or you're packing and
unpacking the data you'll get to the
point when you're doing scripting you
don't really even notice or think about
it until
you're like oh yeah that is a tuple
remind you on that one but it does come
up a lot
and then another strange thing i can do
is i can do a
star list now in this list
is a variable and a is also our letter a
just from right above and i'm going to
set that equal to a tuple and let's
print that out let's print
a comma list and if i run this
you'll see that i get 5 which is our a
and then it creates a list out of the
remainder
so once i've pulled a out of the first
part i now have
list in there and i could have done a
comma b comma c equals tuple so this is
straight from up above where we have a b
c equals tuple a comma star list just
splits them up into two parts
the first part it refers to is just the
value and the second part it puts into a
list
square brackets so you can see how
that's set up in there and how you can
pull that information
and manipulate it and then we'll finally
we'll look at set
and you can create a set s equals and
usually you denote it
with the squiggly brackets and one
two three three four
five and if you look at this if you
remember the set should not repeat
any values so if i print set and i run
this
i now get one three four five and i've
got rid of all my duplicate threes
so i can only have unique values in a
set and
if we're looking at this this is also a
subgroup
of a tuple so that means that if i do s
of one and i try to change one of the
members in there
equals one so i'm trying to change
position one which is a three to a one
and i run that it's going to give me an
error i can't change it i can't append
to it so it's just like a tuple i can't
change
these values in the set what i can do
is i can take a list and let's just
let's just change this
we'll go list equals we'll change these
to square brackets so now i have my
standard list and we'll do a list down
here print our list
and then i'm going to print and we'll
use the keyword
set and we're going to change this from
a list to a set
and then i'll go ahead and print that
out and if i run this you'll see that my
list has all the values
but the second i convert it to a set
which is a special kind of tuple that
doesn't let you repeat values
you'll see that it gets rid of all my
duplicates so now i have one three four
five in there in my set so now we've
looked at a lot of different ways to
store
our data in different variables we have
our list variable
we had our basic variables we had our
tuple we showed you how to do a set
let's start doing something with this
information we'll start with
arithmetic operators the most basic ones
plus
minus divide and let's just take a look
and see what that looks like
and uh we'll need some variables to play
with so we can look through the basics
and if you remember
we did a comma b equals or b equals a
comma b and all that we can actually do
a comma b
equals 10 comma 5. that's nothing more
than what we already did
just a little different formatting what
i'm saying is the a equals the 10 the b
equals the 5. that's all that is
and i could write that out a equals 10 b
equals 5 just as easily
and our basic arithmetic operators
you're going to see is we have
a plus b we'll do this ctrl copy
put a bracket around it so we have our a
plus b
set up on here and if we run this we
should get what we expect
a plus b 10 plus 5 equals 15. and we can
do that
all kinds of different ways fact if we
look at all the basic
operators let me just do it uh no let's
keep it this way we can take this and we
have instead of a
plus b we'll do a minus b and let me
grab that and put that over here
and let me just go down this and do them
all in one shot there we go paste them
right in there
and mostly should be pretty familiar the
first four are your a plus b
a minus b a times b a divided by b
and so we look at that we get a plus b
is 15 a minus b
is five ten minus 5 is 5 multiply them
we get 50
a divided by b gives us 2.0
and now we hit kind of an unusual one we
have a
double slash b2 what this is saying
is that if there's a remainder let's
just convert it to an integer remember i
was telling you
earlier i sometimes have to slice my
data so into thirds
instead of going length divided by 3 i
could do length
slash over 3 and that gives me an
integer and it just tells me hey where's
my
first third of data in where's that at
but if you do that you also want to know
what the remainder is
so that's what the amber sign is is a or
percentage sign
that's what the percentage sign is a
percentage sign b equals
0. and then finally you can square it
and whoops i forgot to put that as a 2.
data science you tend to do a lot of
squaring you do like the square means
error
so it's very common to see something to
the power of 2.
and so you'll see that a times times 2
gives you u squared value this is
actually b
b squared is 25 5 times 5 is 25.
so these are your basic arithmetic
operators there's
really with the first four there's no
surprises you just have a surprise here
when you do a double slash because it
returns the integer and just drops
the decimal when you have the percentage
sign it gives you just the return value
so 5.5 comes back as
0.5 and then you have your the double
star
is your squared so b double star 2 is
squaring your value
and we can take any of these functions
and assign them so i could do
res as my variable equals a plus
b and then res now becomes equal to
a plus b which should be 15 when i run
it and sure enough there's my 15.
so now i can take a and b and they might
come in from all kinds of different
areas
and set another variable that goes out
to where whoever needs it returns it to
the other part of the program is res
and again this is true whether we do a
plus b a
times b a divided by b any of those
basic functions is going to give us
the set the variable res to that now we
can also
do what they call shorthand for a lot of
this so we'll do
counts the most common one you do a
count equals zero
because you want to know it runs a
process adds one to it runs a process
adds run to it so we can do count equals
count
plus one and then if i print count
you'll see right here we get
count equals count plus one i get one
zero plus one is one
i can also do we'll just do it up here
count
equals but instead of putting the equals
argument but plus equals
one and this means i take count and i
might as well put the count here
and the plus sign and we can run that
and you'll see it now equals two so i
get count equals count plus one
count plus equals one is the same thing
so i've added another one to it and now
i have
two and we can actually do this with
anything in any of the main
i could do count times equals so itself
times
1 and of course 1 times 1 is 1 so we'll
do something a little bit more exciting
like 1 times 3
and i get 3. and we could do this
instead of with count
let's do a divide equals 2 and let's
print a
and if we run that we get 5. so i've
taken
a which is 10 i've divided it by 2 a
divided by 2 is 10 and again any of
these
operators that we just looked at i can
now do down here
and there's the integer version we can
do the percentage sign
run that has a zero remainder so that's
what comes up with it
maybe remember i was doing thirds if we
do thirds we can see i get a remainder
of one
if i do uh divide a divided by three
there's my three point three three three
three very common but then i can also do
the double divide
and i get just my three out of there so
a whatever your arithmetic
operator goes here equals threes is the
same as a
equals a whatever operator you put there
in the three
so we had our basic arithmetic operators
uh we want to look at relationship or
relational operators
and whenever you think of relationship
think true false
is this true or is it false and again we
can do our
print we'll go a comma b just so we have
it down here
take this out it take clearing my
palette a little bit there and so we
have our 10
5 and then we can do a print a
is greater than b and if you're
listening closely i said think true
false
is a greater than b is 10 greater than 5
and if we run that we get true and if
you
remember we did with arithmetic and you
wonder where i'm going with this you'll
see that we have
all of our basic operators we have a is
greater than b
a is less than b a is greater than or
equal to b
a is greater than or is less than or
equal to b
a equals b notice this double equal sign
a little different there and then we
have an asterisk on the bottom so let's
go ahead and run this
and you can see down here is a greater
than b true
is a less than b that's false is a
greater than or equal to b
it's still going to be true is a less
than or equal to b still going to be
false
and then a double equal sign well
because the equal
sign is used in python to set variables
and to set values
whenever you do a logic where you want
to know if it's equal you have to use
the double
equal sign that's very important and of
course
is a equal to b the answer is false
remember double equal sign and then if
you're going to have an equals you
should have a not
equals so here's our knot which is the
exclamation point
and you can see that a is not equal to b
equals
true so as we go through here we have
our logical our basic
relational operators which are logic
gates on here and
we can take this up a notch to do this
let me just go ahead and create a little
bit
of different data here and in this case
i'm going to create an a1
b1 c1 equal to 10 20 30 and of course
we print those out as you guessed it it
should be just those values individually
take this clear my palette a little bit
and run that and you can see we get 10
20 30 down here
and if we pop up this is where it kind
of gets interesting is we're going to
print
we're going to use the same operators we
were just using but we're going to do
c1 greater than a1 we're going to add an
extra logic in here
and c1 is greater than b1
so i'm asking here's c1 equals 30 is it
greater than 10
and and is a greater than 20. and if i
run that
we get true because that you know it is
c1 is greater than
a1 c1 is greater than b1 now what
happens if we had
a1 is greater than b1 and
c1 is greater than b1 well if we run
this we're going to end up with
false because a1 is not greater than b1
but we can instead of n we can do or so
if i run this
we'll now get true because c1 is still
greater than b1 so there's our or value
and you can stack these i could do a1
greater than b1 or c1 b1 you could end
up with a very lengthy
logic statement at some point you gotta
avoid that
you have to find another means to do
that but those are two basic ones is and
and or and then finally not so i can
take any of these logic gates
and i can change them from a1 is greater
than b1
to not a1 is not greater than b1 so
is a1 greater than b1 no this would
return
false but then we just reverse it with
the not and it comes out as true so
let's go ahead and clear this and we're
going to look
at a very complicated i don't know if
it's really complicated we're going to
touch upon
what easily becomes a complicated
subject which is bitwise operators
in python so you can imagine let's just
go back to
what is it we had our a b 10 and five so
let's go back there and pull that back
in here so we're gonna have our two
variables a b
ten and five and we're gonna look at bit
wise operators
to understand the bitwise operator let's
go ahead and print
binary of a go ahead and do the binary
of b and we're not going to dig too deep
into this i just want you to be aware of
it
for more advanced programming and you'll
see it comes out here here's the bit
value
which is your 1 0 1 0 and this would be
all zeros up until there and that's what
the 0 b
means it's binary and everything else on
this side is 0. and this is the same
thing
5 is represented by 101 10 is
represented by 10
10 in binary when you switch it over so
we look at this binary switches
we're going to do that we can go let's
do print
a and b so if we run this
we end up with 0 and that's kind of
interesting because how the heck did
they get 0 out of that
you know this is 10 10 and 101. well if
you line this
up this one on the right hand side lines
up with the zero
so guess what that's zero we take this
zero we landed up with this zero and
guess what we get
we get zero there's no and it's not the
same value
and we have one and zero so we are doing
a if this equals this if this equals
this and if this equals this
we get print a which prints out was it
print out
zero because none of the match and we
can do something like print
a and you use the up down bar and unless
you do a lot of work with this you
almost always have to look it up if
you're dealing with binary number or
with
shifts and things like that of where
these decimal places are and so we're
going to do
a or b if we run that we get 15
and if we print let's just print this in
binary so you can see what that looks
like
so if we print a or b in binary let's
run that
so remember up here we got zero i forgot
to convert print print
let's try that again let's print this in
binary and if we print this in binary
you'll see now that it's an
or so we have one or one equals one
zero one zero or one equals one one or
zero equals one it gets kind of
confusing there but you can see where if
either one has a one in its
place or a it then comes out as one and
so we get one one one one and it does
turn out that when you print this out it
came out as fifteen
so if you do a binary or statement on
these two numbers you get 15 on there
and we can do this we can continue this
down there are
exclusive so we can do print
and we'll do this instead of a or b
we'll do an exclusive which is your
little tilde we can run that and it's
going to return the same thing because
this is exclusively one so if this had
been one one one one
and this has been one zero one zero we
would have seen the one zero one zero
come through
on the exclusive where the or returns
all ones
and if you have exclusive um you can
also have
one's complement so this is like
negating your number
so we can do we'll just do this binary
and this is the other squiggly
of a and we run that and we'll see that
this googly comes out as 101 one so it
reverses it
it's a little different on this because
we are looking at a one's complement on
there
so it changes your logic thinking on
there and unless you do a lot of work
with it
can really tie your brain in a knot it's
kind of fun to figure out if you play
with it
and then finally we have a couple more
cool things you can do this this
we can do uh print we can do what they
call a shift
and i'll go and put this in binary
because it's really hard to make sense
of it if you're not doing binary and we
can do
shift two this shifts it to the left so
you can see right here
we've added two zeros on the right hand
side to our a
and we have the same number and shifted
it all to the left
and we can also shift it the other way
shift it this way
and we can run that and now we just
shift it off and these two just get
bumped off
and we end up with the last two digits
the one zero because we're shifting
everything to
to the right oops i'm sorry we dropped
the one zero did it backwards since
we're shifting it
to the right we lose this one zero and
we end up with just this first one zero
and this is when you get into like a
huge array of trues false yes no
and you need to compare them and you can
do all kinds of cool things in here
again it's a very advanced logic when
you're doing bitwise operators but it's
important to know they're there
and understand what they are so when it
does come up you know where to look for
them and
finally talking about logic we'll need
to go ahead and look at
membership operators very useful thing
to have let's just do a list equals
i will do one two back there one two
three four five uh so we have our basic
list and the question is
um let's assign a variable x x equals
two
and so let's go print x in
list and what do you think that's going
to print is x in the list
is 2 in there and the answer is yes so
we get true
so it's going to print true in there and
you can remember we can also add the not
in there is
x not in list we run that it equals
false
and when we start looking uh later on
here or shortly at our um
if else list and wireless you'll see
where this comes in handy to get these
true false statements on here
and then we have identity operator clear
our palette
identity operator and this is all let's
do
x equals 10 y
equals 10 and let's print x
is y and if we run this we get true
because remember when python points to
the memory
it stores the 10 in the same place and
so x is y
and if we change this to y equals 12
it will now give us a false because
they're no longer equal so
you could also replace this with x i
don't do a lot of x y
is y it does come up so you need to be
aware of it but it's not usually just do
x
equals y false but x is y i changed it
to 12 so again
false and then you can also go in here x
is not y so is y or is not
y and it's true it is not y so these are
all the
basic functions arithmetic functions
that you find with your python
install what we're going to cover next
is what happens
if it's not in there what happens if you
have some more complicated math
equations you need to run well at that
point you got to import math
so the import it's important to know
what the import is
if we have an external module to python
so it's not part of the basic python
code
you import that module and math is used
so much
that they have it bundled with the
python install
but by default it doesn't load into your
ide into your user face
or into the program so when you go to
use math you have to run the import on
there
and let's just take a look and see what
some of the stuff that math covers
now i did a quick bing search and it
took me to python
this is always nice because we have the
actual version here which version of
python you're in the documentation
python and then we went to the math
module and in the math
module we have ceiling we have copy the
sign
fabs factorial floor ceiling and floor
kind of interesting because it's just
really from an external viewpoint it's
rounding up or rounding down but there's
other things that go on behind the
scenes that you might use this instead
and then there's here's our basic
functions and if you scroll down
uh you can see it just covers all kinds
of different things like is it
finite is it infinite is it a nand
modify f
powers so if we're going to do an
exponential we saw how to
square a value but if you wanted to do
something to the third or the fourth you
have to import the math module to do
that and you can see here
we have exponential of one this is like
uh exponential x minus one
log x all your log functions are in here
square root
there's one that comes up a lot in data
science if you're going to take the
square means of a value
for your error cosine signs tangents all
the different trigonometric functions
all this is in the math and really we're
not going to cover all the different
things you can do in math because that's
its own
domain if you're working with degrees
and radians or
hyperbolic functions there's just a lot
in the math
module including mathematical constant e
tau infinite nan pai there's your pie in
there so all this stuff is in your math
module and when we're in here we can do
something simple like print
math pi if i run this it should give me
the value of pi which it does
3.141 so on any of the functions in here
if you import
math you could import something like
this you could import
another option let's say i wanted just
the pi value
and we could do something like this we
could also do
from math so it tells it to go to the
math module
import pi if we do this we don't need
the math in front of it we're just
importing the pi
and i can run this and now you can see i
have pi here
same thing and we can do all the
functionality that you saw earlier
let's go back to import math and instead
of pi
let's go ahead and do go and do a
variable so we can put in x
equals 9.5 and then from here from our
math
we could do if you remember from the
very top they had the ceiling which i
said was the same as rounding it up we
could do
print ceiling of x and if i run this it
should give us 10. so
ceiling is actually the nearest integer
that's greater than 9.5
you could also do again there's a cosine
tangent all of these functionalities are
in your math module let's see what
tangent looks like 0.0753 there you go
and then there's a couple that i
see regularly in the coding one is power
so i could do x equals 9.5 y equals
let's stick to three
and we can do x to the y or x
cubed and we can see we get 857.375
i use the power when i'm trying to
figure out how long it's going to take
to run
certain programs especially when you're
going through a lot of permutations
you might find yourself going okay i got
three permutations and each permutation
has three different variations well
that's three to the three
so if i run it once through i can guess
at the time it's going to run by doing
three to the three and then i can just
program it to guess what my
time output is another one is of course
square root so we can do the square root
of
that's another very common one square
root especially in data science when
you're computing the error we can do the
square root of x
so we can do the square root sqrt
of x and if i run this i'll print the
square root again you know data science
the
square root means error there's your
square root
factorials that's another one of those
things that come up probably not as much
but if we're doing the factorial we'll
do y this time and we run it
this is adding up all the numbers up to
three
so this is one plus two plus three and
it equals six
again those are just a few of the
different mathematical functions you can
do and you can go over to python and see
the full
slew of them on the website so so far
we've looked at
data types storing data math functions
so some things that you can do with the
data that comes in let's go ahead and
cover
another area we're going to go into
input and we'll
look at this is a very basic way of
inputting data and
more specifically uh inline input
so this is not your windows interface
or frames interface or windows xy
interface and there is
interfaces for python whether you're
exporting it into an html
or some other format that then feeds the
data back into python there's a lot of
different options there
but this specifically is just inline and
what that means is we need to
find a way to get the data in so we'll
do name input there's our input command
and then the first part is the prompt
this is what it's going to prompt you
for
it says enter your name and we'll add a
the scoop i like to call it but backward
slash in this case
n this stands for new line that's what
this little these two symbols next to
each other is and the backward slash is
a
escape key so if you actually need to
put a variable in with a backward slash
like i want
enter your let's do enter get
your name this will print a backward
slash and this will prompt us
for our name if i hit enter you'll see
enter get
your name and when i click down here
type in richard which is my name and
hint enter then it continues the code on
there and then we can do something with
this
we can do print and we'll do hi comma
name and remember with the print this
just simply prints whatever the first
one is comma the second one comma and so
on
and so i can now hit this in here when i
go down here it prompts me for my name
enter get your name maybe it's kind of a
weird way of putting it hi richard we'll
change this from get to enter
input and we might continue on down here
so we'll go ahead and do input
age i'll do page equals input enter your
age
and we'll do that same backward slash n
and this time
instead of printing the age we're going
to enter in a an
integer this is kind of a very important
thing to know when you're doing line
inputs
if i run this and we print type of the
age let's just go ahead and go through
this
enter richard and it's going to say hi
richard enter your age
we won't put down my real age we'll say
i'm a young
25 it's actually significantly less than
my age and this is interesting because
it takes the input
and it's a string that's what this class
string means so whenever
you do an input like this it comes in as
a string
and that's important to know because if
you're trying to add age to something
it's not going to come out very get an
error so i could do print
age plus five because age is a string
when i come in here and i just do this
real quick miss build my work my name
type error must be string not integer so
it's trying to add
5 which is an integer to a string which
you can't do so that's very important
when you're coding you start getting
those kinds of errors that's where
they're coming from
is you've got to make sure your two
types match and one way
i mean you can convert it i don't
remember from conversions
i can simply put integer age we'll do
integer age plus one
just you can see how it's different and
it will convert it to age
or to a number on here to an integer we
enter in our name
we enter in our pretend age and you'll
see that it
now is able to add one to that age
because i've converted it to an integer
you can be a little careful with this
because
you might have characters in there that
aren't integer in which case it'll give
you an error at that point
let's do two more things with this let's
go ahead and print with a format
so we have name and age and let's say
we'll do
first formatting and we'll put an s in
there is second formatted word
years old and if you remember from the
formatting
we can now take this add our amber sign
at the end or percentage
and then we put the two variables name
and age in here and then i can go ahead
and run this
and if we run this we enter it's going
to click down here if we run this i can
type in my name
type in my pretendage if you said tuple
you've got that right so you gotta
remember i'm sending it as a tuple it's
what the curve brackets do to it
so now we run this it should give me a
nice format on here so it looks pretty
sometimes that's really important
because people are coming in see this
all the time
instead of these nice forms that come up
we used to see it where i do prompts
like this for people
coming in and we'll see that we get an
error down here because d
looks for a decimal we have two strings
so we could do something like this
integer age
and now if i run it i shouldn't have any
errors on there i should come in here
25 and there we go richard is 25 years
old
and so we did a couple things in here we
now have our formatting
we now have string versus decimals what
the d stands for that's pretty much any
number
and make sure we give it a number so we
have a setup on there and you would
probably want to double check their
input if this was for a form fill out or
something like that although
this usually i use this for small
programs where i'm testing something out
and i got to put a different
input in each time i don't use them very
often but it does come up it does come
up where you might need to test
something out real quick or have a line
input for a very long script you're
running and they just need a simple line
input
and one of the last things we can do on
here is we can take this
and let's say instead of enter
input name how about a word and we're
going to do on this
word if you remember from before we had
our indexes for our list well a word
of any kind is nothing more than a
string of characters and that string is
stored in
a list so i can come in here and take
name and i can say hey i just want the
first
four letters of that of your name maybe
that's what it is
and we'll print we'll just keep it name
maybe you're creating a
username or reference i've seen this
where they have passwords and things
like that set to the first four
letters i hit enter it's going to return
rich just the first four letters
and that's because this index works just
like it does in a list it's the same
index
as it is a list before we move on to the
next section
one more thing i want to note about
input a
equals integer if you remember correctly
we did a conversion where if you had the
number in here three a character this
converts it to an integer gives you an
error if you put a in there we can also
do this
as a single line this is very common in
python to try to bring stuff together
they call it the python way
just makes it a little easier to read
let's say you can see right here enter a
multiple of
we'll do five in this case this actually
converts it
so if i go ahead and put in down here
print a
we run this to five we get five and if i
type in the type
of a it will of course see the list of
type integer
we'll just go ahead and run this real
quick print five
class integer so this is just a way of
combining the conversion with the input
you can put it all in one line like this
make it nice and compact so what we want
to cover next
is the if statements and there's like
the if the else the lf
we're also going to start into the loops
we're going to cover the while statement
which uses the logic gate in the loop
and then we'll look at the
four or four statement which is just a
loop without logic
and of course there's a couple of odds
and ends break
and continue which go with the loops so
the if statement this is where we start
doing something with the data we're
putting in so you'll see here i went
ahead did uh
input enter multiple of five and maybe
we want to know
if it is a multiple of five so if a how
can we do that we can do
a divided by five and get the remainder
off of that
is not equal to zero so just a little
simple logic there this returns true
false if remember we covered all that
true false statements so if it's not
equal to zero
then it doesn't then if it's equal to
zero it has no remainder so it's
multiple of five if it's not equal to
zero it has a remainder which means that
it is then
not a multiple of five and we can just
simply have a print
and we'll just uh we'll do this we'll go
a comma not a multiple of five and if i
run this
and i enter in and let's just enter in
three three
not a multiple of five and if we have
another piece of code down here we'll
just print
this is what happens next so we might
have some more script down here
and if we run that we enter in five it
just goes right down to this is what
happens next and if we go back we put in
four
you'll see that 4 comes up and says 4 is
not a multiple of 5
this is what happens next and so the if
statement
only runs if this is true and it runs
whatever is indented so here's our
colon and here's our indent python is
very
big on the indents that's how it tells
what piece of code
is different from the next other
languages use
different like a semicolon for java if
you're in html you have to put a block
at the beginning at the end
so every different scripting language
has its own setup and this is how
python does it you do an indent right
there so make sure you're very careful
where your indents are
and then let's go ahead and just do
enter number and if you can do an
if statement we can also have else
statement
and the else occurs print a so if i
wanted to know if this is even or odd
we could do this i could do if a divided
by
2 the remainder of that is not equal to
0
then this is going to be what odd so
this is an
odd number this is an even number
just some basic logic there and if we
run this i can now come down here enter
in
4. it says 4 is an even number and then
this is what happens next
and we can also do this if i enter in a
5 5
this is an odd number so just some basic
logics you can see right here
either it is even either it is odd the
remainder is not equal to 2
else whatever's next and the only other
option is it's even now this might be
good if you're just doing a simple
you have two choices we can also do the
l
if statement and we put that in before
the else statement
l if and then of course we have our
logic here
and we'll go ahead and combine some
logic we're going to do a couple things
here let's go back up to this
enter a number a copy and enter a number
we'll have a
number a b and c so we'll go ahead and
have three different choices
take out this last line and so the first
choice we want to know
is is a the greatest value so we could
do a
is greater than b and a
is greater than c so if a is greater
than a and
a is greater than b a is the
greatest number so we have this over
here and if we have that we have
l f we can do let's say b b is greater
than a
and b is greater than c we'll go ahead
and do this
we'll do a print statement print b b is
the greatest number
and if a is not the greatest number and
b is not the greatest number that leaves
one other option
so go down to our else statement and
we'll have else
c is the greatest number and if we run
this code here we enter a number we'll
enter a one
two three and it says three is the
greatest number and of course if we run
this code again
you do three two one it gives me an
error because i accidentally
hit a character string there three two
thirty two
two so if we do this and we do 3 2
1 we still get 3 as the greatest number
and finally we could put it right in the
middle and it should still pull it out
we could do 1
3 2 and i'll still come up with 3 is the
greatest number
you can actually go take this as far as
you want so we have just here the three
choices
you could have if else if else there are
other ways to do that when you get more
than here but for basic python
this covers most of the program you're
doing with the else and the else if
statement as far as the logic statements
involved in there
the last thing we want to really look at
is a nested
if and else statement and we can do that
we'll keep the
get rid of some of this stuff on the
screen clear our screen here
and we can do is we can go uh enter
let's do enter
your age and we'll call the variable age
up here so we're going to enter the age
and we want to know
oh let's say this is are you available
for a certain discount maybe it's a bus
fare discount maybe it's um you get a
discount for a restaurant or something
like that
so we have here we enter your age and if
a
let's do a is greater than 64.
so if a is greater than 64. we put our
colon in there
and this is actually age print i will
print you are eligible for
senior citizen discount and maybe we'll
be a little nice we'll make it if you're
greater than
60. how about greater than or equal to
60. we're really feeling generous
so if your age is greater than or equal
to 60 you get a discount
else will print you are not eligible for
a discount we'll go and just run this
real quick
and so if you are 66 it'll come up
you're eligible for a discount
and if you put in 40 it will say you're
not eligible for a discount
and then we come along we realize oh hey
we have discount also
for people who are under a certain age
we have our youth discount
so we'll go ahead and come in here and
we'll say oh if your age is
less than 18. let's do less than or
equal than 19
less than or equal to 18 print and then
of course we can do
see you are eligible for a minor
discount or
youth discount and then we need to come
up here if we want to do this if age is
less than 18
since it's nested we'll do an else here
and if i put the else down here
a couple things to notice about this
list so we have our first statement
if age is greater than or equal to 60
you're eligible for a senior citizen
discount and then we put the else so any
logic
whatever happens under this else this is
always going to go
if i move this else back out it'll give
me an error because you can't have two
else states
and certainly you could do this as an lf
statement here too so this is kind of
another way of doing an lf statement
sometimes you want to add some let's put
a note here
sometimes you might have additional
script here so before you can do these
two calculations you might have to do
some kind of calculation here that's why
you want to do a nested
if and else statement instead of using
the if alif and else statement
and we can see here if i run this enter
your age
now if you enter the age 9 you are
eligible for a minor discount
and of course what we did before we have
somebody who's 56
you are not eligible for any discount
and of course
if you're 64 or 60 or older you get that
nice senior citizen discount
and if you were listening to earlier no
i don't qualify for the senior citizen
discount
quite yet although i do look forward to
it the next thing we want to start
covering
is our loops and we have the while and
for loop
and so the while loop utilizes your
logic
to let it know when to how how many
times to loop through let's go ahead and
take a look and see what that
script comes out as we can do is let's
go ahead and take a word
equals to oh let's do python since
that's what we're programming in
and let's do i equals zero let's say
while i is less than or equal to 5
and since this is we use that indent
just like we did the ifl
statement we still need that indent in
the colon there
while i is less than or equal to 5.
let's go ahead and print word
and then we're going to do i if you
remember correctly we're going to
increment it by 1 we can do a plus
equals 1. same as i equals i plus 1
so i plus equals 1. and if we run this
we'll come down here
and you'll see it repeats the python in
this case five times
and we can even do something like this
let's do i comma
word and let's run that and you'll see
we get 0
1 2 3 4 5. one of the things always to
be aware of
is we did i is less than or equal to 5.
if this was an
actual length of the array you would
have array out of bounds because
remember
you don't want to include the length of
the array because 0 to 4. so a lot of
times just remember unless you actually
want to print
zero through five we can do while i is
less than five
print i i plus or equals one and then we
get our
zero one two three four python now
there's other ways to do a loop like
this and i'll show you in just a minute
with the for loop this just gives you an
idea
here's our true false statements and
just like we did before you could have
if i
is less than five or i is less than
eight which would kind of be redundant
but you could have your or an and and
you could have a very lengthy logic gate
right here long as it returns
true or false so we use the while
because we don't know
how many loops you want to go through on
here in this case we actually set it to
5 but maybe we're building a list and
let's just go ahead and do this we'll do
a list
and create an empty list let's get an
input and we'll uh we'll call it c and
it says
enter 1 to add elements to list and 0 to
exit
loop the while loop we've created a
variable and then an enter here and the
input
if you remember correctly we're not
converting this to an integer so we're
going to just go ahead and
keep it as a character so we're going to
say
while c does not equal and because it's
a character we've got to go ahead and
put the brackets around it to let it
know it's going to be a string
the string of 0. so long as this doesn't
equal 0 keep doing and then we're going
to do here on our while loop
is we're going to have another input
here and on here we're going to have
input enter an element to add
to the list that's the input integer
this one isn't it we'll just keep it as
a great input i kind of like that
keep it uniform on there and what we can
do let me just go ahead and copy this up
here
so we're going to start adding elements
and the order in which we do this is
always important
you never know how your loop's going to
go i switch that around because i want
to append
to my list c so whatever we enter in on
the first one gets appended to the list
and then we ask for the next one
if the next one is a zero so whatever we
type in there is going to be added to
the element
and the order as i was saying is
important because
if we put this after the second input
whatever you put in here is going to
ignore
and if we put it before that's going to
keep adding it in until you put 0 in the
0 if you put this after the 0
it will still add the 0 in so you'll end
up with a 0 at the end of the list
so by putting it before this input we're
going to have both the first input going
in
and whatever input we add in and to get
a view of what this looks like let's go
ahead and print
our list when we run that you'll see it
comes up it says enter 0 to quit
and other to add to list but i can add
an a in
we can add a 3 in a t remember i didn't
put any bounds on it making it an
integer or anything like that and i'll
put the zero
and when i put the zero there it is a
three and t
so this while loop keeps going until it
hits something that says
okay we're done and then it just kicks
it out so it finishes the loop
comes back up here says is this true if
it's true we do it again
if it's false then we skip out of the
loop and then it continues on down below
where we printed the list
now if you remember from earlier we had
the i plus one
and we just looped through to print
python out four times certainly there's
better ways to do that
instead of adding all that math in there
and we can do that so
word equals let's do python so we can do
that real
just simply by doing a for loop four
doesn't require logic we do four
we'll do w in range 10 and let's go
ahead and print
w comma word and if i run this
we'll see we have python printed 10
times let me just take that down a notch
since my screen display doesn't show up
as much uh so range three
and if you remember from earlier range
does 0 2
3 but doesn't include 3. i could just as
easily put
0 comma 3 in here and i'll get the same
answer
and you can also add a step on there
there's a lot of controls you can add
with range so we can print
w range of three and that's pretty cool
just prints word over and over and over
again
what we can also do with this is we can
create a list so i can create my list
there's our square brackets and we can
do one
two let's add hello we'll add a sub list
which is one two three and so we can do
on this
is i could do instead of a range
i could do object in list
so for object and list i want to print
just the object
and if we run this you'll see down here
we have one
two hello and then it printed the one
the sub list the whole sub list in there
one two three because one object in
there
so it just iterates through each entity
in the list
and prints it right out what we can do
next is we can kind of
combine some of these so you've seen the
for loop we have our
if statements along with some different
logic gates we can do
so we can do let's do this let's go word
equals
input and let's do enter word so we're
going to get a word from you off of your
keyboard
let's do count equals zero and we're
just going to count vowels we're going
to use the loop to count the number of
vowels
in word so for i n word remember from
before we can iterate through each
object and when you do a string so if we
have
if our word was equal python we have
p-y-t-h-o-n
each one of those is an object in that
list that's an actual list so we enter
the word that's a list of letters
so this is just going to go through and
look at each one of those letters and
we're going to say hey
if i'm in it we'll give it an array if
it's uh
a e i o u or capital a capital e capital
i capital o capital u
these are seen differently they're very
different characters on there
we have our s our colon here this lets
us know we need to indent
at this point we know it's a now so we
want to go ahead and count
plus equals one and then we just want to
go down here and say
print number of vowels in
oh let's do a little formatting s is
the if remember we got to create that
little tuple at the end with all those
different values
and so here is our word and our count
so let's go ahead and run this and for
the word i'll go ahead and enter in
count and we can see the number of
vowels in count is two
and sure enough it's got an ou in it and
if we run this again
and let's do counting we can see that
there's three vowels in there oh you and
i
now when we're talking about loops both
the while loop
and the for loop and this works actually
on any
the continuum break will work any kind
of indent
so even the if statement i can add a
break part way through the if statement
and it will kick it out
so it's important to know but we want to
know about break and continue
and how those work so let's go ahead and
create a little script here so we take a
look at it and break is
just like you think it is whatever it's
doing it it stops it it breaks the flow
so let's go ahead and do this we're
going to do a range
2 comma the integer of n
divided by 2 plus 1. we're going to look
for a prime numbers we'll see if we can
figure out how to find a prime number
and so what we have going here is i'm
going to take n which equals 49.
and to help me find the prime number
we're going to go all the way through
let's see in range 2 to n divided by 2.
we're going to add one
to it now for the first part we don't
really need to add the one but i'm going
to show you in a minute that
for another piece of code we can put the
one in so i'm just going to leave that
in there and we're going to just divide
by each of those
i's so i is equal to 2 3 4
5 6 all the way up to 25
so it's basically 2 to 25 and we want to
take the the
and we want to divide by that but we
want to know if there's a remainder
that's how we can tell if it's a prime
number because if it has no remainder
then we have a prime number so n divided
by i
the remainder of it if that equals 0
then this is not a prime number so we'll
print
this is not a prime number and instead
of
this is we'll just go ahead and do oh
let's just do something simple and
is not a prime number there we go now if
we picked a number like
20 it will get to four and print this is
not a prime number
it'll get to five this is not a prime
number it will get to ten this is not a
prime number it's going to print that
three times
we don't want it to keep printing that
we want to stop we want to say hey we
got an
answer it's not a prime number break and
if we go ahead and run this
we should get 49 is not a prime number
it's divisible by 7. we do know that oh
the number 11
is a prime number so if i run this it'll
just go through the code and say okay
we're good this is the kind of thing you
might do
if you have an input and you're checking
the input to make sure they're valid
inputs
you want to come up and say hey this
isn't a valid input kick it out
or if it's a valid input go ahead and do
the process on there and if you're going
to have break
we also need to look at continue and how
that works
and so let's say instead of looking for
a prime number
i want to know all the different numbers
that divide
into the number i want to know what it's
divisible by and so we can do that let's
do if it's not
equal to then divided by i is not equal
to zero
i want it to continue um else what i
want to do is i want to print
let's do our place marker we'll do d
is visible by this is also going to be a
number so we'll do another d
for decimal then of course if you do
this part we're going to have our tuple
on the end
and in this case we want to do our
number n is divisible by
our number i so let's take a look and
see what's going on with this code
continue unlike just says hey here we
have our loop
or it could be a while statement for
statement so here we have our loop i get
to here and it says
okay if this remainder does not equal 0
i don't want to do anything after this i
just want to go back to the top of the
loop and so it skips this line down here
it's like an else statement right here
else do this so this is one way you can
almost put an else statement here
instead
so i can run this and it says process
finished because 11 happens to be a
prime number we'll set it to 20 since i
brought up that earlier and we'll see
that 20 is dividable by
2. it's divisible by 4. it's divisible
by
5 by 10. it just goes right down the
list and so this gives you an idea of
how you can utilize the continue when
you're in one of these loops
to use that logic to help you get the
script to do what you want it to do
the next topic we wanna cover is gonna
be
some more advanced modules as you get
more and more advanced in python
you really are starting to look at all
these great modules that are developed
by third parties
one of the greatest drinks in python is
you get a module to do
almost anything and two of the modules
we want to look at
are arrays and numpy these are in data
science they're so important for storing
information and manipulating it and the
difference between an array
because we have remember we did lists
remember lists from before our list
they equal within the brackets and a lot
of times
you'll you might have caught me once or
twice hopefully you didn't but you
probably did or i call the list
an array in python they're not the same
thing
that's very important to note because a
list is a base
python list of objects where the array
is a special module you bring in and you
got to be careful when you're talking
about other programming languages
an array is what a list is in python so
you might hear that terminology
they probably have some other
programming languages and they do have a
lot of similarities so we're going to do
from
array import star so we're going to
import everything we have from the array
setup that's all this means so from our
array we're importing all the different
sub modules in it you could probably
just get by with import array at this
point because that would do a similar
thing but we will let you know that
there is a difference there
and we do an array we just use the array
command
code and then we can create the array
inside the brackets
and just like a list we can do
all kinds of things with this as far as
mix and match but one of the nice things
about array i can also tell it it has to
be of a specific type so in this
array here i'm designating these are all
integers
sent to it a list of integers one two
three four five
and if we print the type of the array
you should see it come down here and it
says okay class array
array has finished so the class is
always going to be an array on here
and this particular array might
designate it as integers
we can also do on our print just like
you have like your regular array you can
access the integers by their index
number so we'll put in
two if we print the array of index two
we'll see that it points to three
so it's just like a list so far so far
it has all
the different setups you would as a list
on here and this includes append
so i could actually take this and i
could go um array append
minus 10. we'll run that just print out
the whole array and we'll see now we
have an array
of type i one two three four five minus
ten something just a pin just like we
did so in other words all the
functionality you have on your list
you're gonna find you have with the
array we'll just go ahead and do a
couple more like that so you can see
what that looks like
let's go ahead and remove three so if i
remove the value three from here you'll
see one two four five minus 10.
if we want to go ahead and print you
sorry i printed the index the first time
we can also do
an actual index minus 10 on the array
let's go ahead and run that and we get
4. this is kind of interesting because
if i did this with a list i would get an
error
by doing the index minus 10. so we have
minus 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and it just kind of
loops over until it gets to the 3.
but where arrays are different than
lists
and this is so important this is what
makes an array an array
we'll take this back here and just print
the array on here
i can do something like this ar equals
ar times three and if i run this
you'll see right here my array has now
jumped
and so when i do ar times three the
array is now
two four five minus ten and it repeats
it three
times so this is one of the cool things
you can do with an array on here
now at this point if you're doing a lot
of functionality
on your array you'll almost always end
up in
numbers python so even though there's a
lot of really cool things
especially the type settings so you can
actually have it all integers
really in this particular module you
want numpy which sits on top of array
and probably the most common form you
see it you'll see
import numpy as np now you can just do
import numpy and wherever you see np
you use numpy now if you are you'll see
when i run this i get an error because i
opened up a new
project in pi chart that means all my
modules that are
added in externally aren't there if you
are working
ide you might go to the command line and
do a pip install
numpy and that will bring it in if
you're using pip there's a number of
different
install packages if you're using jupyter
notebooks under conda or anaconda it's
conda install conda does the same thing
as pip except that it's
brings in all the different sub packages
pepsi most common one your
pip install but we're in python pie
charm and so in pycharm we want to go up
to
click on that file once we're on file we
want to go down to
settings once for under settings we want
to go under our project
and then you'll see project interpreter
this is really cool that we're actually
in here because you can see underneath
here we're using python36
so if i had a rollout in a different
version i could go in here and add those
versions in
and switch them around i just have the
one on this particular machine and i go
over here to the plus sign on the right
hand side
and i click on there and then for
installing in here we'll type in
numpy and once i have numpy you'll see
uh there's different versions of numpy
on here
generally you want to ignore all of
those unless you're doing something
special and go right to the one that's
just
straight numpy and then click on install
package
then pycharm will take over it will
install the numpy package into
this particular environment this is when
the beautiful things about
using pie charm is it keeps this
environment separate from everything
else
and then once it's installed we can now
go back close out of here
out of settings and there's our numpy
added in there so now it shows me what i
have installed on here this is such a
great tool
because i can see exactly what i'm using
in this environment and now when i run
it
you'll see i don't get an error for not
having the module so you got to make
sure the numpy module is installed and
this really is if you're doing
data science one of the bread and butter
tools you need
is your numpy setup your numpy array and
we'll go ahead and create our first
numpy array we'll call it ar one equals
np
dot array so np for numpy dot array is
the command
oh let's just do one two three i guess
i'm being a little boring as far as what
i'm putting in it
and then let's go ahead and just print
that and see what that looks like print
this is an array made with a list
there's other ways to make an array but
we're just going to print
our ar1 we put a list in there so we
just doesn't need a list into it
and then we print our ar1 and we see
that it comes out it looks just like a
list
one of the catches is there's no commas
in here so if i wanted to go ahead and
let's say
take our list you're going to say why is
this so important there's no commas in
there if you're doing a lot of debugging
and you see this first one you know
you're either in an array or list
if you see the next one you know you're
in numpy so it's just kind of a quick
flag
in the programming script and debugging
for some of the things you can look for
now the numpy array starts to take a
major shift here this is where this
becomes real important
as far as the setup we'll talk about
shape
and sizes and matrixes here in just a
second but let's go ahead and do this
we're going to create two
sub lists so remember that from before
we have this one list two
i'm going to do that i do need to put
brackets around it this is a 2d
sample and you can look at this as being
one of the common things is x
y coordinate so i might have 1 2 3 for x
4 5
6 for y and if we print that out you can
see as it comes down here
printer ar1 it prints it out no commas
but you have your two different lists on
here
and we can do something uh like this we
can print dimensions equals and then i'm
going to do ar2 dot in
dimensions so if we run this you'll see
it comes out with i have a print or
setup on there and it has two dimensions
and that's pretty easy to see we have
dimension one which is a one two three
and dimension two which is four five
six likewise there's also size
and shape and so if i do this set up on
here we can see that we can get
the size dimensions is two the size is
six
just how many entities are in there and
then the shape this is
i don't know how many times i look at
the shape of these things because you're
putting it through
some kind of format and if your shapes
don't match
when you're doing machine learning and
you're doing a fit and a train
you'll get an error and so it's so
important to double check your shape and
make sure it's correct make sure we have
a two by three
matrix in this case and then finally
just like you can do this with any of
you know type command we can also get
the what they call
d type in numpy so in your number array
we'll see
that the type of elements is an integer
32 so it actually returns what kind of
elements i have in here and they do they
all look like integers on there
let's go ahead and take a short detour
here and just take a look at the
numpy official site so if we go to the
official numpy site we'll see right off
the top
scipy.org which is the group behind it
it's all open source
you can actually go in here and donate
to it and it is so extensive i'm just
going to look at
data types and so data types gets its
own tab and you can see from here we
were what integer
there's so many specialties you can do
with this and so they cover
just about every data type you can think
of there's our integer 32.
so here's an integer 32 that is the
standard that's usually what it converts
to
if you're converting from directly from
python into numpy but you can force it
into any of these other different kind
of data types on here so it has a lot of
diverse use on this
obviously we can't cover everything
under numpy there's
array creation input output with numpy
indexing broadcasting bite swapping
structured arrays
each one of these is a significantly
large topic
it's its own class if you will you can
see right here we're going to do that
we'll try to cover just a couple things
so you get a little flavor of numpy
so let's take a look at we have our
numpy stuff going on let's go ahead and
look at filling an
array with zeros this comes up because
sometimes you want zero as your
placeholder
and so you begin your process with
filling it with zeros or ones or other
values and you can simply do
np dot zeros and then this
is important is it needs to know the
dimensions we'll do a
two by two and we'll do a d type equals
and there's our integer so we're going
to fill it as integers on here
let's go ahead and take our z and if we
print this out
and run that you'll see that i get a
nice two by two array
filled with zero so maybe i'm doing
plotting i don't know what the plots are
but i need to have it pre-filled
yeah a lot of test data does this you
can create your own data and make stuff
up and
do all kinds of things there once you
have it pre-formatted and if we fill it
with zeros
we can also do fill it with almost
anything
so instead of zeros we'll do a full and
let's do
two comma three and then instead of
let's just do
fill it with let's do one and let's run
this
and when i run this you'll see that i've
created a two by three array
all filled with ones and just like our
list and everything else
we can come in here and we can access
the different indexes
of our numpy array in this case we're
going to do index
one comma two and when i run that
we get six where does one comma two come
from
well remember we count from zero so
there's zero
one and we count from zero we get zero
one
two and so if we do this arrangement one
comma
two is going to be the row followed by
the column
and just like any of these we can get
very complicated we can do something
like this we'll keep this as one
and we could also do so we'll do one we
have our comma
but i want to do after the comma a colon
there then i'm going to put in another
colon
and if you remember from before that
means we're going to do a step and let's
do minus 1. so this would look a little
familiar
this is the same kind of format you got
from list and if i run this
we're going to look at the ones so 0 1 4
5
6. i'm going to select all of them
that's what the first colon is
and then the second one says hey but i
want to go backwards we're going to step
minus 1.
and so we're going 6 5 4 on here that's
why you get the 6
5 4. and we could also do something like
this we could add in
2 1 and if we run that you'll see that i
get 3
2 1 because it doesn't include 1. if you
do up to 2
and then we get 3 2 1 6 5 4. so now we
have that the first two in reverse
0 and 1. and you can just play with this
different ways to select
different entities in our numpy array
and although we can't dig into all the
different aspects of a numpy array
i did want to bring up one last thing
which is operations on a numpy array
this is pretty cool because i can take
this
and here's our numpy array we've created
we can do something like this we can
take
print array 3 and let's just add 10 to
it
and this is a little different than what
we've seen before so if i run this and i
add 10 to it
we run it you'll see it adds 10 to every
entity
in the array so i have 11 12 13 14 15 16
and so on
just adding 10 on there and likewise i
could do all kinds of different values
like times 10
so there it is multiplied out by times
10. there is
other functionality like you can sum it
so we can sum all the values in there
you could also select just a slice of
this so you could select
let's do the first 0 and then sum it and
so we get six
one plus two plus three is six so
there's some there's
min there's max the slew of commands
just goes on and on and on there's so
much you can do with the numpy array
and some important things to note
there's also what they call
transpose and this comes in a lot when
you're graphing because you might have a
graph
that looks at x y let's go back to our
2d array
and it wants all of x y but your array
came in as
all the rows so you have 1 comma 4 2
comma five
three comma six and you need to
transpose it if i run this
you'll see that i've gone from one two
three comma four five six
to one four two five three six tends to
be the other way around there's times
when you need
the individual pairs and of course we
could go back
and transpose it going the other way of
course this doesn't work because
when you do this it doesn't do it in
place
you have to let it know it's in place if
you're going to do that that's we'd have
to do something more like
ar 3 equals ar transpose
take this t out and now we should get it
where it flips it from
the original values to 1 4 2 5 3
6 and back again so we can move the data
back and forth and transpose that back
and forth quite easily with this
so we touched a little bit upon the
basics understanding of numpy that's a
really powerful tool
we need to move on and look at functions
functions are
so important in python they're kind of
programmers bread and butter so let's do
a function
just call this a fun and in our fun i
wanted to print
simply learn so what i'm doing is i'm
creating a function
that allows me to call this piece of
script whenever
i want so instead of having the loop do
this i now have the function do this
and instead of maybe i have this
function where i want to print simply
learn them
at five different places in my program
instead of retyping it
i can just wrap it all up in a wrapper
function wrapper and we can simply just
call this
the way you call it is you just type in
the name fun because that's the name of
our
function a little confusing there for
fun simply learn is fun i like that kind
of combination and if we run this
you'll see it just simply prints simply
learn because this function executes
whatever's in this
indent and you can see right here is our
diff that's it no it's a definition
the name of our function and then a set
of brackets right here now
if we want to do something you know it's
exciting just to be able to print
something maybe we want to add two
numbers
and let's go ahead and do a comma b we
can now put these numbers
in these brackets and this function now
sees these numbers in here
and we go ahead and print oh let's just
print a
plus b and i'm gonna do come down here
and go
add and we'll do five four comma five
we'll run that and if we run that you
see four plus five equals nine
well we might not wanna just run it we
might wanna actually have a value
come out of it and so instead we'll do s
for summation
equals a plus b and then i want to
return
this value so now i can come over here
and i can do
we'll just call in for number equals add
four comma five and if we print in
you'll see this whole process
now brings it all together so now i have
my function
i'm sending it a comma b it's going to
add a
comma b and it's going to return the
results for that and then i get that
under my end so i set this variable
equal to that
and i print in and something i want to
point out is that this
return s is a tuple and we'll talk about
that
again in just a minute or let's why not
we'll just go ahead and do that now
so we have our summation and then we
might have the difference what's the
difference between
a minus b minus b and i'm going to leave
this just as
n so you can see what that looks like
but we're going to return s
comma d the difference sum and
difference and if i print it out
you'll see that it returns nine that's
our s and d
is a minus one and it's in a tuple form
so s comma d
returns this nice tuple we can also
instead of doing this
i could do n one comma n two and then we
could print n one
comma n two uh and we did this earlier
we are assigning variables it's the same
thing
but instead of assigning this in one
comma n two equal to
whatever they are nine comma minus one
we're having it return
from our function so it comes right out
there and then we can print the two
different values
and then this is kind of an interesting
thing we can come up here
and preset our values going in and
instead of a
i'm sending it four comma five i'm going
to say a equals one
b equals three let's do is the other way
around let's go five
if i run this now remember last time we
sent it four
five and i got nine minus one now i'm
sending it four five and i still get the
nine
minus one but if i take this out and i
don't send it any values
it'll automatically default to the a
equals five and b equals three
and then we get our eight two five plus
three is eight
five minus three is two so we've covered
a lot so far as far as the basic
definition
sending it information returns it as a
tuple
one of the tricks you can do is a star
args they call them args and quarks
and we're going to talk a little bit
about what the difference is between
args and quarks
they are designated with the asterisks
so this is
args now i don't have to call it ours i
could call it my args
that is not specific to the program and
we can just go ahead and print
i always like to do lowercase for the
first letter
and then when i change names uppercase
and that's just kind of a
python standardization for naming your
different variables
and if i print my args we can come back
down here
and i can do let's just call this call
this
ak for args and quarks oh spell it out
args args underscore there we go and so
if i go
down here and i go hey let's uh call my
function
paste that down here and we'll come in
here and i'm going to put in one
two three four it might be i don't know
how many
values i have going in i just know that
i have a bunch of values that are going
to come in
and i know what order they're in and so
you can see right here it takes my args
we print out my args and i typed in one
two three four and that's what comes in
and we could do something like this
we could print args of one because maybe
that's a specific
setup and it'll print two one is the
two's in the one place that's our index
and if we're doing like addition we
could do something like
c equals my args
zero minus let's do addition plus
my args one and you can guess on here
if we return call it a we can come down
here and do
a equals args of korgs and then if i
print
our a and i run this you can see it
comes up with three
because one plus two equals 3. and it
might be that
you only do stuff if 3 and 4 exist
let's just do it this way well this is
fine so you can see right here that we
can now
send it whatever args i want and it will
do those
in a list so i could send significantly
more values in here than is up here
and that's okay and that's how your args
work again the asterisk
so where does korg's come in what does
kw args mean well instead of
my args let's go star star
let's go astro gastric or star star my
kw args and let's just go ahead and take
a look and see what these look like
let's print them out
grab this variable up here and again
it's a double asterisk this lets us know
that this is a core
and down here where i'm calling my my
definition
i'm going to go ahead and change this up
and i'm going to say a equals 10
and b equals 20. and then
we have return a let's just take the
return a out for right now
and just have a print it and if i run
this you'll see it comes up with
a 10 b20 we haven't talked about
dictionaries
we didn't cover dictionaries yet it's a
special kind
of set and the way the dictionary works
is you have your index or key and it has
a value
and the index or key is immutable you
can't change it
you can delete it you can add it but you
can't change it and you can change the
in value
and so you can see right here we have an
index of a and an index of b
and so i could also do print my works
and instead of doing 0 i can now do a
and we'll do addition i'll do plus my
quarks and b hit the wrong button there
okay plus my quarks of b and if we run
this of course you got to make sure this
is a string
the a value here is definitely a string
coming in we can do print my quarks of a
plus my quarks of b
and you can see that we get 10 plus 20
equals 30. so this is just a really
cool way to send information to your
function and have it be able to like you
might have all kinds of stuff in here
you need to send
once you send it you can do all your
different processes you can also do
if you remember from before i can do
something like this let's do this
if a in my quarks
and e in my quarks
then print my quarks of a plus my quarks
of b
and you can see right here if i change
this instead of two a i can change it to
c
and run it and it'll say hey i've got a
value of c i've got a value of b
but because i a is not in there i'm not
going to do this addition so you start
to get into
some logic gates that make sure you have
the data you're processing in there and
what you're working on
and then one last cool thing to remember
is that our definition
is an object so like any other object
and we'll talk a little bit more about
objects here in a minute
i can assign it to a variable so i can
do d equals my args quarks
and then i can do d of i'll do a equals
one
comma b equals two and if i run this
and go and run that uh you'll see our
first run which we already had up here
where a
c ten b twenty and then you'll see i ran
it again this time it has
a equals one b equals 2 and it sums them
together as 3.
so you can assign this value you can
assign this whole definition
to a variable the final thing we want to
touch upon
with our definition and our functions is
the recursive
we've already discussed the whole reason
having a definition is i can now call it
from
multiple times from different parts of
my program so that if i know i need to
add certain numbers together
i don't have to replace this code in
every time i need that i just access my
definition in a single line
so recursive means the program this
definition
calls itself and just like the
while statement you run the risk of
running an indefinite loop
and of course if you're stuck in an
indefinite loop that will eventually
crash
your program you're running and so we
might have we'll call this
definition rec for recursive and we want
to take in and we want to do something
with it
so we might say hey if n equals 1
print n and return uh so when we hit the
value of one on
end we know this recursive function is
done that's what this is doing
but if it doesn't equal one we might
want it to
print in and then we could do something
like this
return recursive of
n minus 1. so let's take a look and see
what's going on here
the first thing it does is it says hey
if n equals 1 we're done with this
loop because it is a loop it's looping
in on itself and what we want to do is
we want to go ahead and print in
and then just return and then we come
down here we say well
if it's not equal to 1 we want to print
in and then we want to run this loop
again with
n minus one so we're changing our
logic gate here's our n n keeps changing
so n
starts off at one value and we keep
subtracting and then we can just do
something like this
i can do let's do a recursive and we'll
redo a three
and we'll run this and i get three two
one
why because each time it goes down here
and it subtracts one that goes back into
this
then it says okay three minus one is it
equal to one no print it out
once we printed it out do n minus one
and so on and you can see right here we
just do a simple countdown
certainly there's more complicated
scripts you can write but you can see
how the simple recursive value works
we could use this to solve a factorial
problem let's call this
factorial def factor n and we'll change
this down here so we call it and run it
and if you remember factorial simply we
take value we want to
return call this f f
equals 1 for i in range
let's see would it be in range of one
comma n plus one remember it doesn't
include the last one so we have to add
that extra plus one on there for our
range
and we simply do f equals f we can
actually do this the python way
f times equals i uh so f equals f times
i
and it just keeps going through and
finds out what all the factorials are
and if we do this return f we can print
our factorial of three there we go and
we run this and we'll get a nice value
six
so one times two times three equals six
we could also do this as a recursive
problem just like before we need
some kind of break that says hey we're
done so we'd say
if n equals one let's just return 1. if
it
doesn't equal 1 then what we want to do
is we want to return
the factorial of n minus 1.
yeah the factorial of n minus 1 times
n that's what i want to do so we take
the value we have and we multiply it
times the factorial of n minus 1. so if
our value is 3
we're going to multiply that times the
factorial of 2.
and we take 2 we multiply that times the
factorial of 1. well 1 is 1.
so you're multiplying 1 times 2 and then
back again to 3.
and so if we take out take out this part
right here
now we have the same code in factorial
using recursion and it just goes right
down the list right there and if we run
this we'll get the same value
6 just like we expected and i want to go
back a step
let's just real quickly go back to here
there we go for i in range of one f
equals we did the
f times equals f or i
so we're going through here and this one
looks pretty good we've gone through
and it adds up the factorial but as a
recursion problem
if you remember correctly this one just
goes to the end we know the exact answer
danger of the recursion one as we go
back here and
do a quick undo is just calling itself
and you can see right here if
n equals one and then just keeps going
minus one and minus one and if i run
this
we get our six but what if the value in
here is
minus three well we keep subtracting we
go minus 3
minus 4 and so on you can already see
there's going to be a problem and if i
run this
it will crash the program because it
gets stuck in a recursive loop and here
you go it gives me the recursive error
maximum recursive depth exceeded in
comparison
so we actually have a limit on there so
you got to be real careful with your
recursive functions but they're also
really useful in handy in a lot of
different
scripting and computations i hate to
wrap up on an
error so i'll switch it back to three
and run it so we'll have our nice value
of six
but we want to talk about next lambda
lambda
is a very useful tool and especially
when we get into
what they call mapping and reducing
functions
map and reduce itself is a hadoop term
and there's an actual scripting code
called map reduce
but it's also a programming way of
thinking
so this is a very important concept or a
number of important concepts we're going
to
cover with the lambda which means
function lambda just is a
called the lambda function and how and
why it works
and how it's used what we're going to do
is we're going to take
our add function from before we had add
a b
very simple function to do we have s
equals a plus b return if i run this
it'll add the 10 plus 20 on there 30
just like you would expect it from our
previous
definitions the lambda function or its
bases is it actually does
all of this in one line of code so
that's the first thing we're going to
start with
is our very basic lambda function l
equals
lambda there's our keyword lambda
meaning it's a function
a comma b and we get a
plus b and so when you see this our
lambda function
i can print l and then we can do 10
20. this does exactly what we just did
with the add function
it takes the 10 and the 20. it comes
across as a tuple
there's our tuple being sent in the
tuple is a b
and then it simply returns a plus b
whatever is on the right hand side so
the lambda
is a simple function now we can get
really complicated by using a function
for the function but you can just put
your simple function here a
plus b l equals lambda a comma b colon
a plus b and we get our nice uh print
l for lambda 10 20. we can also do some
kind of filtering in here
so we'll do let's create ourselves a
list here's a list of letters
and let's say i want to take this list
and i want to filter it out
so we'll give it a variable here for our
lambda we'll just use
x x is very commonly used in lambda and
then we'll put over here
x in and let's say if you remember from
before when we did the vowels
we had our a e i o u and if we run this
and i go ahead and print
l pop that back in there and run forgot
we're doing a filter function
i forgot the whole of it we're gonna do
a list and we're going to do
this list of a filter so we'll need
brackets for the list
i'll have my filter and then i'll need
brackets for the
filter what's going into the filter and
the filter comes in here we're going to
put the lambda in there
so let's break this down i'm creating a
list from that list i'm filtering out
and i'm going to use the lambda function
and the lambda function says hey for
each
entity in this list i want to know if x
is
in a e i o u and if it is in a e i o u
then at that point i want to go ahead
and add it to my list
and so here we are adding it on to the
lst over filtering the lst and we're
returning the value to go into this list
what you can do is you could imagine
that instead of this being
a list of these it might be a row in
your database you're processing so you
have a lot of data coming in and you can
see right here it filters it out
it gets rid of the b and the f and we
end up with our aeoa
it filters it out so imagine that you're
sending it a row in your database
so for each row we want to know what the
the lambda is and it processes
each character in this data this could
easily be
an array or columns you know from your
row we might have column a name
first name last name address and you
want to know which one of these
is part of something else so we've
covered
a filter what i want to cover next is
mapping
and a lot of times when i work with
filters and maps
and i'm working with data the
terminology map
when you're thinking map is everything
you can do to one line or one row in
your database you don't need all the
other rows to look at it
so mapping is another tool and the
actual
use of map with lambda we'll do a result
equals equals map lambda and then we're
going to take each
character in there and we're going to
just go ord we're going to
convert it to its ascii code and we're
going to add one to it so we're just
going to adjust it to each one
and i forgot and took out my actual list
of course pipe charm already remembers
it unless i restart the
pie charm environment so it'd still work
if i ran it so we have our list a b
e f o a then we're going to get a result
let's go ahead and print the result
and run it and you can see right here uh
result
and we'll convert it into a list and so
when we print the result
uh we get b c f g p b
i'm guessing you know a the next one up
would be b b the next one up would be c
e the next one up would be f and so on
and again when we're talking about
maps the mapping part of a program it's
whatever you can do on
one line of data and i bring that up and
i keep saying that over and over and
over again
because when you touch upon data
processing especially
big data this is how we're able to cover
terrain terabytes of data is we process
one row at a time
and that's the mapping they call that
that is literally the mapping we are
mapping something
if i look at this road data i don't need
to know anything else about the database
other than this
row of data and that's how i'm going to
map it and if you're going to map
something you need to go ahead and
reduce it
because if you have a ton of different
rows in a database or whatever you're
working with in this case we're just
working with characters in a list
we want to reduce it to something
everybody can read something you can
process at
a glance we do need to go ahead and
import reduce so we'll do that from the
function tools
import reduce that makes it much more
legible instead of doing fun tools dot
reduce
and then we'll do our results equals
reduce lambda x
of y x plus the y of our list
and all we're saying here is for each
element
that we look at we're going to divide
this up and then we're just going to
keep adding it on
to our list and then if we print out the
result
we run it you'll see we end up with a b
e f
o a and that's from the original list
remember this lambda result is not fed
into here this is the list that's being
fed into here in fact let's go ahead and
remove the map
i'm going to keep the map up there and
reduce so we mapped it
and then we take so we're processing
each individual character in our map
we're processing each individual
character in this list
changing it tacking it onto the list it
returns the differences and then we're
going to bring them all together
so we're doing a reduction reducing it
into one string down here
so we've covered a lot we've had our
functions
we looked at our lambda the next thing
we want to look at is modules
and we've already been looking at that
without even knowing it
and we'll start with i'm going to call
this i renamed this one mod1.py
this is stuff we already did earlier so
we had our prime of a
our even number of a def prime of a
equals 4i and range 2 comma a
if the remainder of a divided by i
equals 0 print
numbers not prime return number is prime
and then we also did
even print number is even print number
is odd so this is something we did
earlier we created these definitions
to let us know whether it's even or odd
i've changed the name
to mod 1 dot py and this is going to be
saved in the same folder
as our scratch so this script that i'm
going to write in here
is in the same folder you can also put
it in your library so if you have your
environment
and you have all your library folders
which has all the other default
python including the modules we imported
this will access either one and what we
can simply do
on this is we can now import our mod1
and so we can do from
mod1 import everything so that's going
to import our two definitions it's going
to import prime and it's going to
import even and so anything we do in
here can now access that
so we can now do n equals integer let's
do an enter
input and enter number so we're going to
have it input a number
and it's going to force it to be an
integer so now we have our in
and we'll simply do print and let's take
a look over here we had from
our module we had print prime of a
or even of a those are our two options
on there that's what we have brought in
so i can do print
prime and we're going to send in back
there and i can also do
print or actually there's no prints
there's no return statement so it's just
prime of n and even of n so the two
things we imported
and if we run that it's going to ask me
to enter a number
we'll enter in 3 or 23 in this case
and you'll say number is prime number is
odd so 23 is a prime number
and it's also an odd number it's an even
rod this could be very complicated
because you could also do
you add a select in here run this if i
have a selection of a
or b or whatever but at this point
you're now writing modules
for your script and you can see how you
can easily
organize a very lengthy program by
having your different
modules built outside of what you're
working on so you're not you don't have
this huge length of like hundreds of
lines of code to read through you only
have the little piece you're working on
and you can share these modules
that way if you're working as a group
just like we imported
math you know very or numpy numpy as np
we can now share these modules with
other people who can then utilize them
for their projects
let's go ahead and close out of this and
clear up my area of i'm working with
and we're going to jump into the next
big topic
that is not meaning that i just knocked
my coffee over and spilled it all over
my desk
but object oriented programming and
we're going to start with the theory
there's a lot of theory behind oops it's
been around for since the 90s
very central to just about any
programming language out there
and earlier when i pointed out that your
functions
we do the def statement def whatever
your function name is that those are
objects we can actually set them to
variables
and so object oriented programming is
what this is all
centered on we have an object everything
in python
is an object if you look at it
programming paradigm that focuses on
objects
every instance in python is an object so
like i just said everything you do in
python you have an object you're looking
at
an object has attributes so we have data
that's describing the object and it has
behavior
methods on the attributes these are your
definitions your functions
and your tributes are your your list
your arrays your numpy array
your variables all those are attributes
and so for example if we have a bmw
i don't drive a bmw myself i actually
have a beatable pickup truck
given where i live i would prefer my
trip pickup truck to the bmw but if i
live someplace
else i would definitely like a nice bmw
to drive around
so for an example you have a year
manufacturer maximum speed
those are all attributes of your bmw and
for behavior
you might have you might display the
speed because the speed's always
changing
so there you go those are all behavior
as you accelerate
the amount of gas going into the engine
changes as you push on the brake
you're pushing on the brake is a
behavior and it's changing the speed of
the car
so we define a class class is a
collection of
similar objects so for example a car
we have bmw we have ford we have an audi
the inheritance
mechanism for a new class to use the
features of another class
so we have a number of different things
inheritance we might have our class
which is vehicles
and then under vehicles we might have
cars cars inherits all the different
stuff from vehicles
so we have inheritance so you can create
a class from another class
the feature preventing data from direct
access is called
encapsulation so when we have our
object programming we have integers we
looked at integers
you can't actually access integer you
assign a variable that has all the
different features and
functions of an integer but you don't
access the actual integer
object you can't but generally you don't
you have it encapsulated so that it's
never altered
and polymorphism is a feature of using
the same function
in multiple ways so you can think of
this
in in our example of vehicles and cars
we might also have vehicles and bicycles
well
bicycles accelerate very different than
a car does a car you step on the gas
a bicycle you step on the pedal both of
them have a similar acceleration you
want to polymorph that function so that
it works the same for both of those but
it does something very different
so let's go ahead and create our class
and we'll call it car we have our
semicolon here which says that whatever
comes after this is indented as part of
the class car
now there's some things we're leaving
out here you'll almost always see
brackets and variables in there we'll
look at that in just a moment let's just
start with the class car
and we might have car type must give it
an attribute
this particular attribute is a car type
and we'll set it equal to
manual and this is a global variable
we've set up on here that's used
throughout the
setup throughout the class car and then
we want to create a depth
and this is a very special definition
remember that's a function for diff
and we call it init it stands for
initialize
and we put a double underscore before it
and a double score underscore after it
what that means is when i create this
class an instance
of the class not the class itself but i
create this instance of this class i
create a variable equal to
car this initializes it and self
means that it's referring to itself
whenever you see self in the class
you're referring to
that instance and we'll look at that a
little bit more closer in just a minute
so hopefully if you're confused we'll be
able to help you with that
we'll go ahead and give it past a couple
variables speed
so when we initiate class we're going to
pass it year in speed
and then self is just part of the what's
passed into the definition
and we'll go and do self dot year
equals year and self.speed
equals speed so up here we have a
global variable and down here we have an
instance feature i use variable and
feature kind of
interchangeably but certainly feature is
probably the more appropriate word but
they are variables also either way
they're the same thing and then let's go
ahead and create
a what's called a static method and you
set it that by doing the
at symbol here and we'll call it static
method
this is a command it lets us know that
this is not
specific to an object or the classes
variable so this is independent
of our specific initiation and uh with
this we're going to do uh welcome
and we'll just have it do a print down
here we'll go print
oh welcome to the car showroom kind of
fun there so here's our
so i forgot to put the uh def in front
of welcome this is
tabbed in so when we do this when i have
our instance
this never changes it's a static method
it's always going to do the same thing
it doesn't matter where it's coming from
it doesn't need to access any other
information in the any other features
in the class car or in whatever
initiated variable i have
and then we'll do something a little bit
more traditional def get
speed automatically does the self and in
this case we're just going to do
print maximum speed is
self dot speed now remember we initiated
it so
here's our self dot speed self means is
the
instance we're creating it's not the
actual class but the
instance and we're going to print that
out and so let's take a look at that
and just see how this all comes together
i did forget one piece of the
of the puzzle just like we have a static
method i'm going to do this up here
we also have what's called class
specific
so when you have a class specific method
you denote that
with class method now remember the
static method doesn't care anything
about what's in the class it doesn't
care about the initiation
it has all the information it needs with
the class method
we need to go ahead and use have
information
this class specific and we did that up
here when i did
class and i did car type equals manual
so that's the feature that we can access
underneath this title and we'll create a
definition here
and we'll call this type we'll just do
cls
because it's a class method that's what
the cls stands for
and then we're going to do print we're
in a nice showroom and we say
these cars are comma
cls.car type so the cls just refers to
the class
class are variables without the self in
front
so when i have a class or a feature
underneath class
any instance i create is going to have
car type equals manual where when i
initiate it and i have
self any feature like self.year
self.speed
is going to be just that instance has
that feature whatever value we put into
it
and then we have a static method which
only accesses
the static method it doesn't have any
other information coming into it from
either the class or external and then
you can see here we have type class
denoted by cls and we can print the
class type and then we have the self
there's our self our most basic
definition
get speed and the way this works is we
have our bm let's do our
here's our bmw so our bmw equals
make sure there's no spaces in front of
it it's going to equal car
and we have our car class back up here
yeah i did it all lower case a lot of
times car the
class is you want to start with a
capital letter you don't have to but
that just is like a kind of a programmer
standard on there so you can remember
that it is a class
versus a variable which we start with
lowercase and if you go up here to
initial we have self which it
automatically sends because this is a
part of the car
and then we have year and speed and so
we want to go ahead and send those in
there we're going do
2018 and we'll say has a maximum speed
of 155
i don't usually living where i do i
don't go over 75 or 80 at the tops
due to the particular laws we have and
we'll do a ford and this particular ford
on their showroom
go to 2016. and maybe your ford has a
maximum speed of 140.
so now we've created two instances and
if i do
bmw dot get speed
you'll see here that it doesn't the self
which i put in here isn't needed because
it already pulls itself
in that is the the instance it's saying
the bmw which i called it
is pulling in bmw on here and all the
features with self are pulled into it
also
so if i run this you'll see down here
that it pulls up the speed it says
maximum speed is
155 for bmw and let's say we want to
know about the ford
maybe we'll do ford get speed
and we run this and the maximum speed
for the ford is 140.
and of course we're looking at the
little ticker tape of the car and along
comes the guy who says
hey do you want to buy a car and we'll
do the car welcome
and if we run that it says messed up on
this because it's a capital c
there we go and we do the car welcome it
says welcome to the car showroom
maximum speed is 140 on the car you're
looking at our salesman's come up and
approached us
and then finally we might be looking
around the showroom and saying hey what
kind of
showroom is this what are you guys
showing to me we can do car type
we see that it comes up these cares typo
there these cars are
and then it looks at the car type and
says manual so you're in the manual car
showroom now this is all great you have
your class car
let me go ahead and just get rid of some
of this stuff take it back
a notch clean it up take out keep our
bmw and four
down there and so with our class car we
now have
under there an init we'll keep the init
where we put in the year and the speed
and we set that
i've taken out my static method but i do
want to add in let's go back and put the
get speed back in itself get speed
and we'll just print like we had before
maximum
speed and because we put it in as a for
the instance we'll do self dot
speed that's how we reference it there
so right now we have our basic class car
that looks pretty good but what if we're
talking about
remember we had like these models are
all standard these models are all
whatever what if i want to have
a class sedan so we're looking at just
sedans but i wanted to have all the
features of the car i don't want to have
to do
a economy a sedan a four-wheel drive i
don't want to redo all the work i do in
car because
the get speed is going to be the same
the year and everything else is going to
be the same
what i can do is we can do an
inheritance and that means when i do a
class
sedan of car this inherit everything
from
car so everything i have above in car is
inherited so any instance i create of
sedan
uses all the values in car and we can do
we can change some things on here but
let me just show you how this works to
begin with instead of doing i can do
this part right here let me just do uh
bmw dot get speed so i still have
my car class so if i run this you will
see
indent error because i forgot i created
the this is here let's go
pass is just a fancy way of putting a
placeholder here saying the code is here
but don't do anything
psyc process maximum speed is 155. and
what happens instead of a car
we do a sedan and we run this i still
get maximum speed is 155. well
sedan doesn't have that in there but
sedan inherited everything from car
so when we look at this i have maximum
speed equals self stop speed
and i admit the initialization is the
same
self.year self.speed on there now we can
also do something like this with sedan
i can take to copy all this over
generally you don't just do a pass here
the very least you need your init file
in this and so here's my initialization
and so with sedan we're going to do
something like this
i'm going to go super.net year comma
speed and what i'm telling it is it
comes in and says okay i'm initializing
a sedan
this is my initialization code but we're
going to go to the class that this
inherited from which is our car
and we're going to do the init there
this basically comes up here and says
okay this is our init
this is how we're going to initialize
this but in addition to that
what i want to do is i also want to do
something like this print
this is a sedan and so now when i run
this our bmw
initializes as a sedan it does the super
so it uses all of the init code
underneath our class car and then in
addition to that is whatever i wanted to
do in this case i want to just print
this is a sedan so you can see it prints
this is a sedan
and then when i run git speed it still
utilizes that from the original class
so now i also have the speed and the
initialization
all under my original class car i'm not
recreating it and retyping it copying it
down there and just like we have defs
appear under class
we might have certain definitions which
are very specific
to the sedan so maybe we have open trunk
so we'll put that in there there's our
definition for open trunk and all it
does is print
open trunk and so i can do bmw
dot open trunk and if i run this my bmw
now can open the trunk so now it has
additional
functionality that cars doesn't we can
see this if i do forward dot
open trunk and if you guessed it it'd
give us a
error you're correct car doesn't have an
open trunk i'm sorry it's an error this
ford maybe it's a ford truck
doesn't have a trunk so it can't open it
so this is only if it's a sedan
does it have open trunk underneath of it
and this just adding being able to add
new definitions is our polymorphism we
can polymorph
our class to do things the original
class couldn't do and we can go ahead we
could take this
oh let's let's change this up a little
bit here we'll initialize this with
name and then self dot name
equals name and instead of having
setting the speeds here
we'll just give we'll just say that this
particular individual car
maximum speed of 150
forget speed and we'll do the same thing
down here we'll have
our instead of a sedan let's do this
oh let's just take this completely out
of here we'll take our sedan and the
sedan
will have a speed of 150. but instead of
us yeah sedan
that works we'll just do sedan and then
maybe we'll also have another one
that is an suv and so our suv class
they all have a maximum speed of 120
name this suv and so now that we have
these two classes
they're both inheriting from cars so
when we send something to them we're
going to send name
self.name and then we have def getspeed
which is going to return 150 class suv
maximum speed is 120. so we're storing
the
name underneath the each instance of it
and then we're also going to get a
different speed each time
let's do a list we'll do a car list
here's our list of cars
there's our brackets for our list and
then i'm going to do something kind of
fun
here here's a sedan now the sedan
is the class so that's an object so i
can make a list of
that object and in that particular
object
we're going to give it a name and the
name of this one is going to be it's a
camry very common car out there
and then i'm going to create a second
object it's going to be an suv
class now remember we also did variables
as definitions
certainly you can put anything that's an
object into a variable so
these are a list of classes on here with
their calls in the suv we're going to do
i guess scorpio i'm not too familiar
with the scorpio car but i guess it's
one of the common suvs in certain areas
so now i have a list of two classes and
these classes are both initialized the
first one with camry
and with scorpio and from before we can
do
four car and car list so we're going to
do each car
and then we're just going to do
something simple like print in this case
car
dot name and kind of a fun one we'll add
the
plus sign in and the brackets and the
colon
and just a second to put this together
comma
end equals double brackets this is
basically we're telling it
don't print a new line i want to print
the car
followed by car dot accelerate
so remember we had actually we did to
get speed so we'll do we'll
stick with get speed control copy get
speed
put in our double brackets i'm just
going to add a space up here and here
oops actually goes at the beginning so
if i run this
it should go all the way through this
list here's our for loop remember this
how we talked about iterating through a
list of objects there's our car list
and as we go through we see scorpio we
have our camry camry has maximum speed
150
scorpio maximum speed 120. so we put
together
a nice set of polymorphism of classes we
polymorphed our our car class into a
sedan
and into an suv so they each have these
print out a very different thing or have
a very different
kit speed functionality but they both
inherit the initial depth
from car we're going to take on seven
parts or seven code challenges
that you can do to take all the basics
we've covered so far in python
and see how to apply them and we'll
start with part one part one we want to
go ahead and see if we can print the
number of occurrences
of each character in a string and this
would be a good time to
pause the video so you can actually try
to solve it on your
own before we go ahead and give you the
solution we came up with now remember
there's always multiple solutions to any
of these challenges
so if you come up with a different one
that's great you know it just means
you're thinking on there
the first thing we want to do is we want
to go ahead and get an input so we want
to go ahead and pull up an input for our
word that we're going to type in
and then we're looking for the number of
characters in a string
so we need some way to track it and we
have what we call a dictionary now if
you remember we briefly touched upon the
dictionary
a dictionary is denoted with two
brackets
and it comes in the form of a key so
you'll have your key code
and then that key code is set to a value
so the value can change the key code
cannot
and if we had brackets around this could
initiate it if you already know your
initial keys and values
with something that looks like this and
we can also
here's our d assign them as we go and so
we'd have our key
and then this would equal our value and
what's nice about these two setups
is that we have a key code which could
represent our
characters and then we have the value
which is going to represent the count
hopefully you remember map reduce we're
thinking map
and reduce this is such a common
question that comes up in map and reduce
so we're going to map all our characters
out and then count them and reduce that
to
in a huge map reduce program you would
actually do each document
have a summation and then that would be
sent and brought together and then
reduced to just a single representation
of it so we're doing kind of the end
part where we're just reducing this word
so here we have our dictionary and then
we want to go ahead
and do a for i loop for i
and s so our input is s and this will
iterate over
each character in the string and the
next thing we want to know is do we
already have d
in our dictionary in this case we're
looking at each of our
eyes so if i and d so if it's already in
there
then we can simply do this we can simply
do d of
i and then you can do the plus equals
and then of course we're just adding one
to it because we're incrementing it by
one now if it doesn't exist in the
dictionary and you try to do that you'll
get an error it'll say no key value
there
so now we have to do a thing where if i
is not in d we do simply d
of i and we initialize it with one keep
it simple
and then finally we've got all our
different things we can just print
d and if i run this let's go ahead and
take that and run it
comes up says enter a string and we'll
do hello
i'll hit enter and you'll see i have h
capital h
equals one lowercase e equals one l
equals two there's two l's
and o equals one you can also if you're
trying to look at it a little bit
clearer you could do
for key and d we could do something like
this
print d of key and you gotta remember it
doesn't actually print the key unless
you tell it to so here's the key in the
d of key so i can also do it this way
see if we can pick another a better word
on here you can actually do a full
phrase in here
so uh welcome to python and hit enter
and you'll see that we have w1
e has two l has one c one o
three m one there's two spaces t is two
p is one y is one h and so on so this is
a very simple
set of loops but it covers a lot of
interesting key points that you'll use
throughout any kind of big data or map
and reduce program
so let's move to part two or challenge
two let me just clear my
palette so we have a nice palette and
what we're going to do for part
two is we're going to insert an element
at the k-th position
of a list and again you know pause it if
you need to let's go ahead and create
our
list and in this case we're going to do
just a standard list we'll do some mixed
elements we'll have like 23.
it looks like they sent me an example of
the list let me just grab that so let's
do
23 hey oh 89 python so we have a nice
list there with one two three four
five objects or zero through four if
you're thinking indexing and let's go
ahead and do this we'll print
let's just print the original list comma
list
and then we need our input n equals
input and i guess we need to put where
we're going to
enter it at so it says input and let's
do enter
on index between they have let's see we
can just a couple different ways
but let's say we do 0 which would put it
at the beginning
and and then at the end how would you
get to know the end
well we could do this plus string
of length uh in this case length of list
and remember we don't want to type in
the actual i guess they could type in
the actual n so it could be zero or it
could be the very end
of the list so this end should give us a
nice input and then let's have an
object or we'll just call it k and let's
just put this above
sometimes it's nice to put these in a
different order k equals
input let's go ahead and have it enter
an element
and so this will automatically be a
string that we enter here
i'm going to go ahead and just add a
space there so it stays on the same line
if you have a larger screen this might
look better if it goes down a line but
in this case i want to go ahead and just
keep that in the same line
and we'll do this on here i'll do plus
and add a space
and this will be our element in and k
for the actual integer and we want to
make sure this stays as an
integer so let's go ahead and take this
whole thing and add integer at the
beginning
it's for our index integer at the end so
now we have our input we're going to add
an element in this case it's going to
always be a string
unless we want to try to convert it and
then we're going to enter in where it's
going to go
and so how do we get there how do we put
that in that list
and so there is actually a number of
ways you can actually do an insert but
let's say we don't have the list insert
command
make a little hard on us let's go ahead
and do this let's go ahead and do a list
append and we're going to append in this
case
k that's the entity we entered in here
so if we pretend not to do the list
insert and we have the append we can
append
our value onto the end of our list and
what we're going to do
and again there's like so many different
solutions for this i mean if i was just
doing an insert
into my list i would just do an insert
but let's say
sometimes you have to do other than
finding out the spot on there you might
be
comparing the values or doing something
else going on so we can do is we can go
for i
and range 0 comma length
of list so we're going to create an
integer that comes in here and just
starts at the zero index
so i for index and just pages through
all of our objects in the list
and we want to know is if i is greater
than and we had our k value
now if you did like i did up here 0 you
could also do k
value equals 1. so this gets a little
tricky on your input if you're talking
about your end
client do they know to start 0 as play 0
or do they start with place 1. so that
might change your coding and how you put
this together
those are things you'd want to think
about and we're going to do temp equals
list of i so we go ahead and we look at
our list and we say okay i'm going to
pull this object off i'll create a temp
here list
of i equals n and we're going to swap
in our n value and then we'll do n
equals temp
so let's take a look at this i have if i
is greater than
k and since we're starting with 0 we're
going to do i
is greater than or equal to k that's
just because we're starting with a
0 instead of 1. and we take we go ahead
and create a temp variable that goes to
that pointer
list of i then equals n that's our last
element in this case it's the one we
entered and then we set n
equal to temp so we take this and we
take whatever's in that position we put
it in temp and then we just go all the
way through
and what happens is it will just keep
replacing that value
all the way to the end and let's go
ahead and see what that looks like
before we do this i guess we have to
print out an answer so we'll come down
here we'll go print
and our updated list comma and this is
just list
let's go ahead and run this and we'll go
down here and let's enter in
hello and i always like to do the
extremes we have zero and five so let's
go into zero
and enter and we have our list which is
original 23 all the way to python and
now it says hello
and puts it right at the beginning if
you're going to do that you should also
test out
the end of the list so what happens if i
put in five and then it comes up and you
see it puts hello at the end
what happens if we put in four double
check
here we go four and it comes up on place
number four and i'll do one more test on
this
just because i really don't like things
going out the door
unless i know they work and we'll put in
one and you'll see here
0 1 2 3 and so on and there's our hello
and you can see here we had a nice setup
on that we have our input
and we just go through it's really
important to note that we're iterating
through each value and we're
seeing if something important is going
to need to change that value this could
be
almost anything this could be that you
need to alter not only insert the value
but maybe increment everything past it
with
plus one or something there's all kinds
of things that can come up little weird
logic that you wouldn't think of until
you start messing with it challenger
part three
check if the substring is present in a
string without using the find method
i remember back in the 90s this was
central to all of your programming was
to do
all these little things now of course
they have find built into the
functionality
so string we need to have our input
we're going to input a string and we're
going to input a substring and we'll
call them st for string and sub for
substring
and i'm going to jump ahead a little bit
here and then come back
because we want to look at something
let's do count equals 0
and then we're going to do our loop for
i and range
0 we want to start with position 0 and
then we want to go to
what that's where the question comes in
well we could do the length
of the string now there's a problem with
this and that is
that the substring might be five letters
long so if i go to the length of the
string
i'm actually comparing the substring to
something that isn't even there so i'm
going past the end of the string that's
not really worth doing so how do we
figure out that number
well we can do l equals length of our
substring so now we have a value for how
long the substring is
and we simply take the 0 to length of
string
minus l and then we want to add 1 on
there
so remember that this length it goes
exactly to that length
without including it so we have to add
the plus 1 in there to include the very
end of that
so zero to the length of the string so
the next question is how do we know we
have it well
if our substring equals string
and we want to start from position i and
we want to go
to i plus l the length of the substring
so if they're equal we'll print count
plus equals one our increment of one
and we'll do print sub string
here's our placeholder s for a string
found at position and then here's our
placeholder
for a number or d in this case and we'll
go ahead and give it just a space off of
here oh that's fine we don't need a
space on that
and then we have our amber signer
percent sign
and our tuple so here's our tuple we
want sub comma i
uh so that put that right in there this
will tell us that it's in there each
time it finds a substring we're counting
it
then we print it out that is part of it
a little redundant because it'll just
print out the same thing over and over
again
and then we can do if count equals
zero we can print substring not
found and of course an else statement
else
print and we'll do substring sub string
here's our place marker again s found
another placeholder d times and then we
can
if you're into your placeholders of
course you have to do your tuple at the
end
and we have our sub comma in this case
count so let's see what that looks like
when it runs oh before we do that let's
just walk through it
so let's take a walk through what we
just did so we have for i equals range
we had to kind of fiddle a little bit
with the length
to make sure we got all the way to the
end but we didn't go past it
for finding our sub in the range of the
string simple if statement says hey it's
here
count plus equals one let's go ahead and
print our substring
found this will be very repetitive so i
don't even know wouldn't normally put
this in here just to keep printing it
and then it says if count equals 0 we
found none print substring not found
and else substring s found d
times with our count so let's go ahead
and run this
and here it goes enter our string uh
welcome to simply learn i'm going to hit
enter and we're going to look for the
let's go 2. and it gave me an error so
what happened here
and i of course get an error hopefully
you caught this error when i was
putting it together this should be a
colon not
a comma this is a straight list so
that's why
you got to remember what rate you're
working in and it does happen
and we'll go ahead and run this again
and we'll do welcome to
simply learn type in our 2 and it comes
up and says
substring 2 found 1 times substring
found
at position 8. so now we know a position
it's at
and we also have how many times it was
found and since i was just talking about
numpty arrays let's do
challenger part four find the index for
the nth
repetition of a number in a numpy array
so let's go ahead and import our numpy
as
np you'll see that very standard and i
went ahead and created an array or
team in the back did so we are going to
create our variable ar
set to a numpy array and it's just one
two four one twenty three one two three
four so
it's kind of a random set of numbers on
here and let's see how we can build this
and at this point
you should be trying to think about how
to do it yourself and let's go ahead
and i'll just paste this in here we're
going to print the original array just
so you can double check it in our output
and we're going to do our input num
equals an integer
and then give a value for the number for
your input so we'll have our num we're
going to look for
and let's do this if num in r
so the first thing we want to know is
even is in there there's always a chance
you might not even have that number in
there
initiating or doing initial case so if
we're looking for
kind of the base case of do we want to
even do anything if it's not in there so
if number
in ar first thing you want to do is
check otherwise it's not worth
processing and then let's do this so we
want to ask the question
what is the index for the nth repetition
so we've got to find out what repetition
the user wants and we'll go ahead and
create another input in
give a value for n which is our
repetition or repeat so give a value for
n or the repeat on here
now at this point there's so many
different ways to solve this we could
iterate through
but we're going to create and you'll
hear the term mask let me just type that
out for you
where you're masking something masking
means that we create
a series of values in this case we're
going to create a bunch of ones
and we're going to say it equals np so
here's our numpy array where
our input array equals our number
so this is going to return a numpy array
of either ones
or zeros then we can actually test it
and see what's in there
now there's other ways we could just
iterate through the numpy array usually
when you're working with numpy arrays
you try not to iterate across them the
whole
purpose of the numpy array is to let it
leverage the back end code
so you're not wasting as much resources
and you know what let's go ahead and
print one out just so you can see what
that looks like
what this masking does so np where r
equals number
let's go ahead and run that and here's
our setup let's do enter in the
number one and value for in repeat
uh it doesn't really matter because
we're not doing anything with that yet
we'll put in three
and if you look at the output of this
mask we've created it's set up and
returns an array and the array is 0
3 5 9 15 18. it returns all the
positions
of our number in the array so here's np
where r equals number and then we just
called it 1.
if you print one out you can see we just
get a nice list of indexes and this is
really useful to us
let's go back in here and then we can
very simply on the indexes
do if we have our n
and we'll do less than or equal to the
length
of our one and remember this is a tuple
coming in this array
so we have the first part is the actual
indexes
and the second part is our d type so we
really want to do the one of zero
and this is important if you haven't
worked with numpy arrays or even if you
work with them a lot sometimes you just
do a quick printout to find out what it
is you're looking at
so you can remember the format on there
and we'll do this if it's less than or
equal to the length of one or zero
then we can simply print one of our zero
position
and then on here we want to do since
that's also itself is array we want to
do
the n minus one remember we start with
zero
so if we want to find out in the how
many is in there or you know what the
position it is
we're counting one two three but the
array is zero one two
so we have to put the n minus 1 in there
and of course if we
don't find it we'll do an else statement
and we'll print
there aren't and then we'll go ahead and
put down a placeholder just we can keep
track of it
currencies of one just keep it simple
this
time and then finally we'll go back here
and he had our original
if number in the r we course have an
else
print that is not in there boom and
let's go ahead and run that
and we have our list down here let me
move this thing back up so we can see
what the run looks like we'll
look for this to look for a one and we
want it to repeat
um a fourth and it returns it in
position nine
there we go and if we went up here and
entered in let's enter in just a random
number
i don't see the number 33 so we'll put
33 in there
33 not in the array so it doesn't even
go through because we put that
initial test right at the beginning that
says hey if it's not in here don't even
bother and then we went through and
counted them now you probably found your
own solution
very central to our solution was the
where statement where it's going to map
out the indexes of this occurrence where
r
equals number and this is part of
masking there's all kinds of ways to
mask your data
usually you mask the whole array across
something when you talk about masking
in this case we're just returning a
simple array where it lists the indexes
let's go ahead and clean our screen here
for
part five generate a dictionary that
contains
pairs such as i comma i
times i where i integer is between
one and an entered value sometimes i'll
break these up if i'm for
readability so we'll do that there we go
so we're going to generate a dictionary
that's the first thing we need to do
and we need a value entered so let's go
ahead and do both of those
and there's a couple ways to generate a
dictionary
earlier we did the two squiggly brackets
you can also just do
d equals dictionary if i run this you'll
see that it works and s for a number let
me go ahead and enter in four
and processes i could have easily just
have also done this
with a double brackets that's the same
thing so if you see something
dictionary you could also these are
equivalent statements
d equals brackets and d equals
dictionary or the dictionary object
and we'll do uh four i and range one
in plus one so there's the number we
entered
and in our dictionary we're gonna do d
of i
there's our key equals and our value i
times i and you could have also done
since this is just squaring it we could
have also done
squared that's the same thing as i times
i i squared but we'll go ahead and do i
times i and then we'll simply because
you want to see what your end is is
print d and let's go ahead and run this
and we'll shift this up just a little
bit
it says enter a number we'll enter 3 and
if i run that
or if i hit enter on there i get 1 1 so
1 squared is 1
two squared is four three squared is
nine and you could go on
as far as you wanted on there i could
enter in a significantly larger number
but it goes up to whatever my range is
on that this is again an example of
dictionary
how to build a dictionary in simple ways
on there all right let's go ahead and
clear
our screen for part six uh write a
program which takes
two digits x y as input and generates a
matrix
the element value in the ith row and the
jth
column of the array should be i times j
there's a lot of ways to do this we're
going to do this as
a list of lists my first thought though
would be to put this in numpy because
numpy can do this very
there's a lot of automated ways to do
this in numpy but let's go ahead and
look at the back end how would you do
this into a regular list
so before we start solving this problem
how do we get our data we have two
inputs what if i wanted to have just one
input
where i have you enter x comma y what
would that look like
take out the space there because that
could cause an issue uh well there's a
couple ways to do this
one is if we want to generate an x y
this member is going to return a tuple
for whatever i do we could do something
like
this so on here we're entering a string
with two integers how do we convert
those well we can do
integer x for x in
string dot split this is a really kind
of a fun
shorthand for python for iterating
through
our setup so what we got here is we're
going to first of all split our string
so here's our string it comes in with 2
comma 3 and then we take and we split it
by the comma
and for each entity in that split we
want to return the integer
of that entity in this case we've
labeled it x and so this should go
through and do x
y and it should return an x integer and
a y integer
and let's just see what that looks like
let me just go ahead and print x
comma y and let's go ahead and run that
and here our x
y is we go three comma two hit enter and
it enters three comma two
now if you're putting out a full package
what happens if you have somebody who's
overzealous
and does something like this 3 45 3
enter we're going to get a and unpack
too many values
so this returned this huge list of
numbers i typed in and gave me an error
so you got to remember that
when you're doing these different inputs
you might sort it out and just look for
the first two of them there's all kinds
of different ways to do this
so now we have our x y if you went ahead
and just did the enter x and enter y
that's okay
and we want to generate a list so our
list
that we're going to put together is
going to be and again we're doing some
nested stuff here which is a lot of fun
we're going to create
a 2 by 2 matrix and so we're going to
have 4
0 for column and range y and for row
and range x so what we're doing here is
this is going to put a 0
in each of these in here and then this
is simply
column is r for column column is nothing
more than a placeholder
i could have done for c in range y same
thing with
row that's because it has to have a
value that shows up here and we're just
going to fill
everything with 0. and let's go ahead
and print this
print list we run this and you'll see
here's our inner x y
we'll do 3 comma 3 and we end up with
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero
here's our two iterations done the
pythonian way
it's going to return we have the square
brackets on the end so it's returning an
array
and for the first one we're going to put
0
for column in range of y and then we're
going to repeat that
again for row and range of x
instead of 0 we can simply do this i can
do
column times row and if we run this
we'll see here's our x y uh let's do
three
comma three again that way it's not too
big on there and we end up with zero
zero zero zero one two zero two four
and we might get a little fancy in this
and do oh you know what let's do it this
way
import numpy as in p and then maybe
we'll do
numpy array equals np.array
of and then we'll enter in our list that
we created
and then let's print in pa remember that
when i see
here matrix i automatically go right in
for the numpy array so we'll enter our
3 comma 3 and you can see here that
numpy is designed for doing matrixes and
so we have zero times zero
zero times one zero times two one times
zero
one times one one times two and so on so
we create a nice little matrix of i
to j and then we put it into numpy just
because
we can and numpy has such a nicer format
on there
so let's go ahead and clear our palette
let's move on to
part seven and in part seven
we're gonna find the hcf of a two
numbers using
recursion and hcf if you don't know what
hcf is its highest
common factor or denominator of two
numbers using recursion um i couldn't
remember it i had to look that up so
let's do a definition we'll create our
little function
hcf and what comes into there is going
to be x and y
and what i want to know is we want the
highest one so we'll do if
first of all y is not equal to
zero if it's equal to zero you you don't
want to divide it anything because it'll
give you an error anything divided by 0.
and let's take that and we're going to
just return hcf
of y comma x and here's a remainder of y
so hcfy of x a remainder of y so we're
looking for this is just the remainder
so it's going to return the remainder on
here
on this else we want to return
x and so we wouldn't need our input on
this before we go any further so let's
grab a
input and we'll do the same kind of
input we did before we're entering
x and y enter two positive integers and
this is just from
a previous example so we'll just go
ahead and grab the integer x for x in
in this case it's not string keep it the
string on there
s t and have our two integers here from
before
keep it simple and then let's just go
ahead and combine it all into one line
pythonian way if you can put it into one
easy to read line
then you should do so so we're going to
print hcff
of placeholder d and placeholder d
is also is placeholder d and this is our
x
our y and then we're going to just print
out the return
value of our hcf of xy let's go ahead
and run this
we're going to enter in two positive
numbers let's go 12
and 18. and so the hcf of 12 and 18 is
six that would be our most common
denominator let's go ahead and clear out
part seven and then uh bonus uh we
are going to throw in a part eight quick
sort so we have
bonus round part eight quick sort and
we're going to
positive list of integers
so we're going to do a quick sort on
positive list of
integers on here there's like so many
different ways to do different sortings
on this
one of the ways to do it is to look at a
list
and then partition that list and then
you go through that partition and you
sort it
and then you sort a smaller list a small
list and so on and so on so that's what
we're going to do on this one
before we start though we do need to go
ahead
and grab our data and set that up
and so you can do it a number of
different ways we can do comma separated
we're going to switch it up a little bit
on this one because it's just fun to try
different things and we're going to do
enter in n number
of objects in the list we're going to
enter each of those values
into our array in our array we're just
going to input
an integer of them print the original
list this should be pretty
familiar because we've done so many
inputs in this lesson in the last lesson
all we're doing on this one is we're
just appending the input
here and how many inputs and still go
down the list
and if we go ahead and just run this
first piece of code real quick
number of objects in the input we'll do
three values of the objects we'll do
three
two five and you can see here's our
original series three
two five pretty basic and
straightforward and because
uh for me space is a commodity as far as
our output and the screen i have for
your catching you on what you're in
there we'll just put it on one line
we'll say original uh list so the first
thing we want to do
is if we're going to do partitions let's
create a module for partitioning out our
data
and so we'll start with a simple
definition procedure
and we'll call it uh partition and we
want to take our list that it's sent
we want a low value a high value and
what we're going to do with this
is we're going to create i equals
low minus 1. so remember this is an
index and we actually started with zero
so now we're actually one less than the
index if we're initiating this with zero
on one end
and the maximum on the high end and
we'll call it pivot
and the pivot is going to be a value
we'll set that list equal to our list
of our high index so remember high and
lower indexes
i is an index pivot is a value that's
the actual value in this position of
whatever we send it so we're going to
send it two pointers
low and high and we're going to send it
the list and when we initiate this
we usually will set it up as a first
entity which is
index of 0 for low and then for high
we'll have
the highest index on there then we need
to go ahead and do for j
in range low comma high so we're going
to go through
all the different values in there and if
list of j is less than
or equal to pivot then i
equals i plus one but we like to do with
the python way
so plus equals one now remember we
subtracted one up here
so this is one less than whatever index
we sent it
which if we start with zero would be
minus one and this brings it back up to
zero so this is why we put this in here
at the top part i'm actually going to
stop here
just for a second because sorting is one
of the most basic things
but it's very confusing as to why the
sorting is so difficult
and one of the reasons it's so difficult
is because if i have the numbers 3
2 1. there's so many different ways to
sort this one i could take and look at
these two numbers
and if this value is higher than this
one i could swap them which would then
give me
two comma three comma one and then i can
look at these two numbers and if this
bigger then i can do
swap them and then i get two comma one
comma three
and then i gotta start over because now
the 2 and the 1 aren't in order and so
you can see with the lengthy list
whatever i do starts running into
factorials
n factorial runs and there's no real
easy way around this because if i
put a reverse list 321 it's going to
maximize how many runs it takes
and so finding different ways to sort
the data depending on what you're doing
can be really confusing so understanding
just what's going on with
this particular sort we're doing helps
to start understanding where this
problem occurs
and certainly there's tools out there to
sort it for you
which are already maximized sometimes
you have to sort on values
that aren't you know the value you're
sorting on might be different it might
be
instead of sorting on j it might be the
remainder of j divided
by something or it might be the
percentage of j over another column
so being able to sort these things is
important and knowing how this
works the logic behind it is more
important than the actual
coding at this point so we get in here
we go i equals i plus 1. so remember
that i put
in this case we did it somehow reverted
there i plus equals one
and then we're going to do list of i
comma
list of j equals
list of j comma list
of i and this is just a cool python way
of swapping values you can see here we
have
j i becomes i j so we're literally we're
swapping the values up here as we go
through this partition
on right here and this works on our
counting because we have i
which right off the bat is set to zero
we have high
which is not the end value but one less
than the end value so our range of j
is going from zero to not quite the last
digit
and our i is going from we've added the
plus 1
and then it goes to the end here so we
have our list of i or list of j and we
swap them out depending on if
listed j is greater than pivot and we
can also do something like this
here's our pivot and we'll just take our
pivot out up here
so here we have our list of high is
going to be our pivot number that we're
switching around and we're just
iterating it through and swapping values
and then finally we'll go ahead and run
this one more time
list of i plus 1 of list of high equals
list of high comma list of i plus 1. so
one last swap at the end
now if you're looking at i equals low
minus 1
let's do this this is kind of fun to do
clean up our code a little bit
i'm incrementing it right here why i
don't know i can increment it right
afterwards and it has the same result
of taking the minus one off of here and
just adding it after i need it
and this then carries down to here where
i have i
plus one while i'm adding it at the end
so i don't need to add it again
and we simplify it down to i equals low
following our eyes through there we have
list of i list of j
listed j list of i swapping here's our
increment and then our final swap at the
end
and what we want to go ahead and do is
we just want to return
i plus 1. and so if we're going to have
our partition
set up this way we're returning the i
plus 1
or in this case just i we want to return
i carried it down forgot to carry it
down there we've taken our list we've
swapped it around
because we're passing the list we're
passing the actual list not just a
pointer to it and then we're going to
return the i so we know what we did
and so if you remember down there when i
did that example the first time through
we swap it around
and then it comes up and says oh okay
we've already swapped the high value all
the way up to the right hand side
then we have to start over so we'll go
ahead and call this quick sort
and the quick sort is going to take the
list a low and a high
just like we did for our partition and
we want to do that is if
low is less than high then we want to go
ahead and partition
the index let me fix my tabs there we go
so pt is the value from the partition
that's coming back that's what says i
returned and so we would go ahead and
partition our list
and we have our low and high value going
in there if we're going to partition our
list
once we get the pt back we can go ahead
and do a quick sort
on the same list low comma pt minus
1. so it goes through the list it moves
the highest value to the end
and then we want to take that pt it
returns and we want to subtract 1
because we know where the high point is
so now we have a shorter list to go
through and we sort it from the other
end
too we'll do a quick sort and we'll do
our list comma
pt plus one comma high
so we're coming out from the other end
so we're basically sorting the
list going both directions on here so
this is our sort on this one we've now
sorted our list so we need to go ahead
and call that
and we can simply call that let's see oh
we can print out the list
let's do this let's go print there's our
original list
sorted list and we'll put our little
placeholder or you know what we won't
put a placeholder
there we'll just put a comma in and of
course it probably helps to actually
return the list
so we'll go up here and do uh return
list
that we've nicely sorted on here and
we'll come down here to this part
and do quick sort and we have our list
that we put in
we're going to start with the 0 for
initiating it and then we have our high
value
which is simply the length of the list
because that points to
it's actually linked to the list minus 1
that's going to point to the last index
and then real quick before i run this
let's do some quick clean up here the
original list
and then we want to create a second list
which equals the original and then we're
going to print our sorted list and we're
going to send it this information for
our quick sort
so let's go and see what that looks like
let's go ahead and run this and we're
going to enter our number of values
we'll just do three
and we're going to enter in three two
one
let's open this up so we can see what's
going on down here so here's our
original list
three two one and you can see it's
nicely sorted one two three and if i was
testing this out
i would enter in one two three to see
what happened i would enter in two three
one
just some quick changes to make sure
it's sorting correctly in fact let's go
ahead and do that real quick
let's go ahead and enter another list
we'll do it four and i'll do
one two three four one two three four
sorts out is one two three four and i
actually know from doing these so many
times that that's more than enough on
these
but just in case let's go two one three
four and one two three four there we go
quick sort for our list
so that wraps it up thank you for
joining us today
for python part two where we covered not
only seven but bonus
eight different parts we went in there
and we looked at
everything from basically finding uh the
elements in what position on a list the
number of occurrence of characters
to dictionary use and key codes and
finally
a quick sort at the end again thank you
for joining us
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead feel free to
comment below on the youtube video as we
do have
moderators who monitor the questions and
post down there
or visit us at our website and we'll be
happy to help you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here